e
sucks
get
good morning
everybody we're only uh let's see we're
three four five six seven do we need a
no you don't need for for uh work
session yeah okay
um to get started in for our committee
meeting this morning I'd like to have
representative ktoa lead us in the
I pledge aliance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
you so on our schedule this morning
um let's see from 930 to 10:00 we are
going to have a work session and disc
just
um uh three of the bills that we heard
hb77 so I guess I'd like to get started
on uh
discussions from members of our
committee I don't know if there's
anybody else in the hallway there that
uh coming in no okay um so we had uh HB
505 allowing the sale of freeze-dried
foods produced in Homestead food
operations and I'd like to entertain any
conversation or discussion about uh that
bill that we heard representative coma
thank you madam chair um I believe um
that the bill could use a little
tweaking and I think um
because uh you know there were some
concerns but if we add it in uh the sale
of Freez dried processed
foods um so they're taking foods that
have already been processed already been
approved uh for sale um I think that
might be a good change and also making
sure that they're using a
freeze dried machine not a dehydrator or
oven and I think because that gives you
more control over the uh moisture
because the moisture content is really
key and that can control the moisture
content um that's just some of my
thoughts on that particular Bill do you
think that um the line right now we have
food the line on page one line 11 that
says food is freeze-dried shall not be
considered potentially hazardous food so
your idea would be processed food that
is freeze-dried shall not be be
considered potentially hazardous food um
I I don't I I don't know do we need to
put in uh shall not be considered
potentially hazardous food or just
um I guess you know there's that section
there but I mean I think the key is is
if they freeze dried food um shall
be from processed food I mean because
obviously if they're
buying
something right whether it's ice cream
or something that's already processed
you would think that
it's we allow the sale potentially hous
his Foods in grocery stores all the
time pro pro processed foods and I think
adding the processed food part really
covers you because that doesn't mean
that eliminates raw meat um and I think
raw chicken because that's not
necessarily
processed um um when we're talking about
Fe freeze drying um I'd like the ability
though to for for them to be able to
also freeze dry berries uh fruit and
that kind of thing so I I'd kind of like
to add that into so maybe it's processed
food and um berries because I'd be weary
of letting saying all fruit because
watermelon which has such a high water
content I would be concerned with and I
don't think anyone would really freeze
dry watermelon because of the high
moisture content of it but I think if we
limit it to berries as a start I mean
this can always be amended down the road
but if we want to look at food safety we
can start off with processed in berries
okay my my other thought in terms of any
kind of amendment would also be to
include that they must use um commercial
equipment um okay so you know what is a
commercial uh freeze dryer right so who
determines commercial okay a
representative guber then
Barber uh uh thank you uh Madam chair
the um similar to that last suggestion
is perhaps on line uh 11 we could use
fruit and dairy products rather than um
those are the two that uh would not
include meat obviously and uh it would
fit into the I think what the intent
was okay represent
Barber sorry I have two comments so I'm
wondering with um defining what can be
used is it possible to put a per food
that has a percentage of
water in it so for example berries are
different than peaches and plums but if
we could find a percentage rate that
would work uh to be more
inclusive is that something to consider
I I mean you know I I don't I don't know
that the water content really has any
bearing on it I mean the machine is
supposed to dehydrate or freeze and then
take the water out okay and so I think
if you have whatever specific settings
on the machine to do that and it
measures that then I don't see really
why there would be a distinction of
making um you know that provision yeah I
agree with you that we you know to limit
ourselves um would limit our Farmers so
um so far as the types of fruit I think
that that's what you mentioned I mean
and so far as like processed food versus
nonprocessed food um I I would probably
specify um anything that wasn't a meat
anything that wasn't meat because I mean
I I guess meat kind of was more of a
problematic
thing represent Bixby and yeah so I
think my my fundamental concern is just
the the phrase that food that is freeze
dri sh shall not be considered
potentially hazardous um having that as
a blanket St statement uh basically
creates a
um creates a way of making something
sort of Legally not hazardous that is
not attached to reality uh because uh
whether some the the the fact of the
process of freeze drying something does
not remove hazards that were in the in
whatever was freeze-dried so I I have a
problem with that phrase and think that
if we want to allow certain freeze-dried
foods then uh what we need to do is set
out uh that there are certain
freeze-dried foods that are exempt from
this uh from from the from the condition
of being potentially hazardous rather
than uh creating a blanket statement
somehow freeze drying food magically
makes it
safe okay um
so rather than saying food that is
freeze-dried should not be considered
potentially hazardous we would have some
other
statement that would say that certain
foods that are freeze dried are not
potentially hazardous but others are or
something like that something like that
so so that um because that's where the
exemption is being made is in this
um so uh I haven't really thought out
how you know how we would do that but
something you know um something that
um so I think that there
are some of it depends on on process you
I think there is there's some process
review that needs to happen with certain
fruits so berries that are you know that
are being that are simply being washed
but not otherwise processed I think that
would that is something that could be um
could be could be um you know freeze
drying would not be a it would be fairly
straightforward with that uh but uh in
terms of um in terms of something that
you need to cut up to freeze dry it uh I
think that there are you know there's a
higher level of um sort of Sanitation
required for that which which doesn't
mean that that it should be
automatically like you know sort of
Suddenly It's it's potentially hazardous
but
um but once you get into um doing
certain um certain Dairy things there's
a much greater range for for contamin
potential for contamination although if
you're doing ice cream I I think ice
cream is something that is fairly
straightforward because if it is if it
is still sound as ice cream as opposed
to being a puddle it should be fine
so okay represent K thank you um you
know and as I said earlier I did have a
problem with the whole U potentially
hazardous food thing also um but to
representative bixby's point I think a
car out you know stating which foods can
be freeze dried but also stating that
they have to use a freeze dryer um in
the operations so that it can't be done
with a dehydrator or anything else and I
think um to start off maybe we could say
whole
fruit
and ice cream to start with because that
seems to be the two main categories that
people want to start with and see how
that plays out um that opens up the
market a lot for a lot of these Farmers
because um you know although some of
them want to do vegetables and I don't
know if we want to include uh vegetables
in that too so um but if we just spell
out ice cream fruit vegetables uh that
eliminates um meat of any kind up front
um although I don't like to put a lemon
on anything but to get the ball rolling
and to see how this pans out and for
food you know food safety you know maybe
this is where we
start uh representative H Haskins and
representative King thank you madam
chair I confess that this um hearing was
challenging for me um I have great
respect for our Public Health Department
trying to protect us from ourselves at
times
and I also thought that the folks who
are working so hard to generate some
income and I think they mentioned yogurt
as one of the things so that's that's
Dairy I wondered if somebody could
explain to me what lines four and five
imply on page
two about
oxygenation oxygen well keeping the oxy
putting oxygen absorbers into the
packaging ensures that there isn't that
it absorbs any excess moisture that
might be on the product or prevents any
kind of condensation from happening
inside the product that would um do does
that answer some of the questions I mean
we're talking about fruit but I heard
apples and peirs might be
problematic um if they were cut
I I still have questions about where the
carveout should be okay
representative Bixby next yes so um
actually an oxygen an oxygen oxygen
absorber is different from uh a uh
desicant oh so um maybe so an ox so an
oxygen oxygen absorber literally absorbs
oxygen and what that does is it removes
the so oxygen is basically drives a lot
of chemical reactions that degrade food
and uh by removing the oxygen you um you
basically um redu substantially reduce
the the rate of
degradation uh and if it's if it is
sealed and if it's freezed right and
sealed uh appropriately then that's
going to keep that's you're not going to
get more water in there but um but but
you want to make sure that there is that
you don't have that oxygen which can
also degrade the food U and for example
they they sell beer caps that have an
oxygen absorber in them that will pres
prevent uh further reaction in in the
beer that you're bottling uh so uh so
that's a different technology um the uh
the one of so I think whole fruit is not
quite the term we want because as some
someone pointed out you know a
watermelon is a whole fruit uh and I I
don't think that anyone is going to like
take a watermelon and stick it in there
free dryer it doesn't but uh but there's
a um the the larger the volume of the
fruit the more problematic it is in
terms of drying it because it doesn't uh
because you the drying happens at the
surface and uh it takes a lot longer for
the moisture to come out of a larger
fruit than a smaller fruit I would feel
better about an apple that was cut up
than an apple that was freeze dried yeah
um representative King and then
representative
ktoa so as the bill stands right now
it's um unfortunately a complete
non-starter for me um I think
freeze-dried food I I almost think of it
as like a new food group um you know
when a lot of these Homestead statutes
were written um freeze drawing wasn't
really a thing or if it was it was such
a big corporate expenditure that only
few people could do it and now with the
Advent of like small freeze dryers
anybody can do it so I think we need to
ask ourselves do we want do we want you
know all of the ins and outs of this to
be dealt with in rules or in statute and
I'm fine with statute I like that but I
don't like the idea of shoehorning it
into this Homestead food license I would
rather it be its own subdivision or its
own section yeah its own section that we
can refer to not just for that's
something that's not just in the
homestead food license but something
that lots of different rsas can refer to
and um and what we can do then is we can
go through and say okay you know these
free Drive these free dried foods are
okay these ones aren't they need this
oxy oxygen absorber they need to be
vacuum whatever we can get really
thorough into that and and go over all
the things that you know should or
shouldn't be part of it um unfortunately
that's probably too big of an ask for
this committee at this time I think what
I would be I would feel confident with
even though I'm not a huge fan of just
creating you know add in item number of
committees to study the issue but like
this is seems like an issue where yeah
if you had you know some stakeholders
involved and some you know Minds kind of
in the offseason getting together and
saying hey let's start a new section
that's just deals with freeze-dried
foods and really get thorough about it
and then maybe next year or something I
don't know um there can be a new section
that really deals with freeze-dried
foods I'd rather refer this to the food
safety subcommittee and and batted
around and see if we can come up with
language I'm amendable to that I'm fine
with that just something other than us
thank you madam chair I just want to
reply to something that uh
representative Bixby said about um you
know cut up Apple and I think where I
misspoke is that they would get in whole
fruit and then from there they could cut
up the apple as opposed to having an
apple already sliced and then they're
trying to freeze dry it um but that was
my thought process because already the
degradation is happening once you start
slicing into that Apple okay
representative Potenza and then
Bixby uh thank you madam chair I um I
agree uh representative King and I had a
conversation about this and when we uh
we had a little bit of a back and forth
um because it having that one line
inserted on the bill um yeah it it it
didn't mesh with the entire you know
statute and um and I agree it needs to
have its its own section and it it to be
defined and all of that that doesn't you
kind of in a sense muddy the Waters of
what we already have currently um this
committee has done a ton of work I mean
in in just in our term our first term we
did a decent amount of work but you guys
you know did all the heavy lifting on
Homestead and changing that and
expanding it um so I just I wouldn't
want that to um to conflict that you
know if we're going to move move forward
I think it should be its own separate
section as well yeah you know I'll tell
you when um when I originally came out
with the dehydrated food uh dehydrated
meat the beef jerky bill I had a
separate section for freeze drying as as
well as dehydrating meat and um that was
all ripped out when uh the drafter said
to me oh well representative shamberg
has this bill about freeze drying
Foods so you can't both have the same
stuff and so I said okay well then take
my take the freeze dried part out and we
went with his bill um and when I saw
that all he did was just make this
exemption I thought for myself well
that's kind of like a real
oversimplified way to deal with this but
you know let's see where that goes and
in my mind yeah I I really do think that
if we're going to go down on the path of
um allowing freeze-dried foods which I
think we should because I think it's
something that you know our our
constituents are looking to do it
expands what they can offer on their in
their homesteads and um I but I do think
that it warrants its own section to be
pretty thorough in what we are allowing
to be done representative Bixby yeah I
like the idea of having a separate
section because I see this as you at the
moment the you know everything that is
get gets you know once you get Beyond a
certain point everything has to be in a
commercial kitchen and it which is a
pretty broad category and it's got a lot
of different aspects to it some of which
you do need to have if you're going to
be U processing for freeze drying and
some of which are com are clearly
Superfluous uh and uh because there are
you so I think that having a separate
section on
what is specifically required for freeze
drying uh and having uh outlines in
terms of what what process requirements
are either are are necessary um and what
level of regulations so that would need
uh and I think I don't think that we
need to have a a huge level of
regulation for cutting up apples uh so I
don't so that's something that could be
in that you know clear laying out what
level of um process regulation you need
for what what types of of um processes
you're doing I think is would be useful
because it would lay out things like you
know someone who has a uh maybe
commercial grade uh freeze dryer in
their home uh and has basically what you
would you know the the quality of um of
uh kitchen that you would need in order
to meet the homestead food requirement
could uh you know could do a fair number
of uh things dealing with produce uh
starting with you know whole freshly
picked Pro produce and having the uh the
the the time Spa time scale from that
produce be produce being picked to it
being processed you know um you within
appropriate uh food safety guidelines
okay uh so I I think I I really like the
idea of doing this as a separate section
um I and
um I'm not sure what it's going to take
to do that but um so I think maybe first
sending it to the to the uh food
subcommittee and then um seeing whether
we can do some something in the next few
weeks and if if it turns out that it's
more complicated than we can do in a few
weeks then uh turn it into a into a
study commit I I'm fully amenable with
that and um our food safety subcommittee
is uh me I'm chair um and representative
wheeler representative Howard
representative barar and representative
Kenny um if there's anybody else who
would like to join uh when I when I
schedule that meeting um and we can we
can certainly discuss uh you know how to
go about doing that I I'll take a a stab
at uh coming up with some language for a
separate section and we can kind of bat
that around and if we see that that just
doesn't cut it then we'll turn it into a
study committee representative k i I
think your bill HB 642 that set up uh
the dehydration of food as its own um
section would be a great guideline for
this bill okay great Y and you know I
have to leave shortly uh and um the
we're we're we didn't get to really talk
about 642 396 or 707 but we we
huh we can we can um pick up the work
session later on today if we have some
time so what I can do is I get out my
gavel from my bag because I didn't put
it on the table and um recess this uh
work session uh for sometime later today
if we have some time uh um otherwise you
know we can continue discussion of these
bills the next time we meet on February
on March 4th after next week we're off
uh and I could just kind of push off
these conversations uh to the next time
so pickiness I don't think you
allowed to reset to some to some time I
think there needs to be a time certain
rbit I don't think that's going to take
from 1015 to 12 okay I'd say 10:30 so
maybe if we recess the work session
until
um like 11 11 o'clock okay we will
recess this work session that
us okay I I will uh recess this I'm G to
say 11 o'clock just to give us some time
uh to 11 o'clock this morning and with
that I am going to depart and have uh
representative ktoa take over for the
hearing um on HB
277 relative to the use of F and
thank
really lot of things going on Iron's in
the
fire um looking forward to the time off
it's
after
minute have like 30 seconds oh okay it's
okay oh I'm looking at two different
please okay
uh the time being 10:00 I'd like to open
the hearing for HB 277
and I'd like to welcome representative
Bixby thank you madam chair uh for the
record Peter Bixby from do straford
13 and um I have uh submitted six bills
this term so far uh and uh this is the
last and least of them
okay so uh there's another bill which
I'm not going to talk about in any sort
of detail coming up in a couple of weeks
that uh involved uh a that involves
revisiting the uh animal cruelty
statutes and uh as when uh a number of
us were preparing that bill someone
noticed that there was an error in
current law and that error is that um
current law reads that um anyone who has
in uh his or her possession an equin
cult that is less than 90 days old uh
that is not being nursed by its
Dam uh unless that cult was born in this
state and has died before the fo uh
before the cult has turned became 90
days old uh and that would be a
misdemeanor uh under an animal cruelty
same thing with selling the cult uh what
this means is that it is perfectly legal
to abuse
Phillies under current statute uh
because a cult is a male baby horse uh
so what this bill does is it changes the
word uh cult to F and makes the language
a little bit neater in a couple of
places uh and that's what the bill does
I hope we don't need to argue about it
I'm happy to take
questions representative King
thank you madam chair thank you for this
bill um so I don't know anything about
horses so I just um can you just clarify
what a dam is and and also um maybe you
already did a fo a fo is just a baby
deer gender neutral okay I don't know
just if you could just
clarify a dam is a mother horse okay uh
it also I believe that there are other
species where the dam is ref referred to
as with the mother is referred to as the
dam as well but in this case it is a
mother horse um and a Colt is a uh baby
male horse and a fo is a baby horse and
um was there something else you wanted
to find no I think that's it now okay
thank you any other
questions seeing then thank you
uh I'd like to call Rob Johnson from the
Bureau thank you madam chair and members
of the committee for the record Rob
Johnson representing the New Hampshire
Farm Bureau as the federation's policy
director and this this is as
representative bi Bixby explained um we
we had some a proposal to amend the
animal cruelty statutes RSA 644 this
bill a bill you hearing this afternoon a
bill you'll be hearing in week after
next uh we we submitted to uh uh chair
Aaron uh uh chair today U representative
ktoa and representative Bixby in in um
seeking them to introduce it to for some
clarifications and and they decided to
split the uh request into three bills
this is one of them and this this is
something that internally we've been
talking about for quite some time we've
seen the RSA and you know uh Phillies
are horses too kind of thing we would
why why is it this way and it may have
been way back uh that there was an issue
with Colts being separated as a as a
guest and that was addressed but but um
Phillies were left out so with that and
there were a couple other spots we
thought needed some changes and again we
we uh made the request and we met with
them and and um in support and thank you
for your time and attention
representative King thank you madam
chair thank you for taking questions um
I don't have the RSA in front of me um
so for my benefit maybe the benefit of
others on the committee and then also
for the public record can you just um
clue us in a little bit about what RSA
644 colon a is the state's animal
cruelty statute okay so so because it's
not really alluded to in f and g by
itself can you just maybe explain how
that cuz it doesn't really mention in in
I in in their animal cruelty can you
just kind of tie that into how it is
with the greater RSA itself with the
greater section I will I'm just looking
uh let's see
here because I think that I think that
there's a certain amount of um
understanding of the RSA already that
goes into the reading of this and for
somebody who hasn't isn't familiar with
that RSA at all just kind of explain it
to me like I'm five um so representative
King as
um Mr Johnson alluded to uh 644 is the
animal cruelty
statute and there are three bills coming
into to change some of the language
there this one being the simplest of it
just because of the word cult um so this
one just deals with the ecoin section
and making sure that any
full under the under 90 days cannot be
removed from its Dam
uh and otherwise um you know everything
else remains intact under that
particular
section um
so yes 644 colon8 is is titled the
cruelty to animals and section one of
that title it it it it defines cruelty
and then two it is a couple of
definitions and then section three which
is this is part of it it reads that a
person is guilty of a misdemeanor for a
first offense and of a classy felony for
a second second or subsequent offense
who and then I'll let ABCD and goes on
and this is where you see f and g if
that helps you okay may I have a
followup please okay so what what does
that mean to have in his or her
possession in in equin full I mean if
you have if you have the dam at your
farm or whatever and it has the baby is
that not in your possession already or
how I just don't I'm just not wrapping
my head around this I'm not seeing abuse
in having in possession a fo that's less
than 90 days old yeah Ju Just to be
clear that's existing language yeah yeah
okay we're not adding anything I
understand that I'm just not
understanding the whole thing yeah I
mean that would be a determination I
would I would assume as to whether you
know who had control of the care of of
the the animal the as far as possession
goes okay
that all right I think I'll just have to
spend some time on my own read rereading
it because I feel like there's little
something missing in the language here
colon8
okay that particular section I'm just
going to read and is exactly what he
said it's a person is guilty of a
misdemeanor for a first offense and of a
class B felony for second or subsequent
offense who and it goes on to list and
section g of that says sells an equin
cult that is less than 90 days
old um that is not being nursed by its
Dam or otherwise you know then it goes
on and and then on Section f it says has
in her possession equin cult that is
less than 90 days that is not being
nursed by its Dam unless the cult was
born in the state so the reason for this
particular change is because
as Mr Johnson said Colt only refers to a
male baby horse and changing it to full
would change the uh statute to be
inclusive of male and female baby horses
it's it's a very simple representative H
Haskins thank you madam chair so the
implication is that the cult is apart
from its mother that's why it's in
possession of or it's sold um and that's
where the cruelty comes in it has to be
with mother till a certain age all right
right unless the dam has died in which
case then you have to basically hand
feed it or find another Dam that would
nurse
it okay okay yeah sometimes the the the
things that somebody would know kind of
go them my yeah I'm
sorry any other
questions uh that was the last pin card
do anyone else wishing to speak on this
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing for HB 277
and uh is there a representative Scully
can you gr me the blue sheet on HB 277
please uh on online there are six people
opposed
me uh online six support one oppose and
there is nothing on the blue
sheet and I'd like to close the caring
you
e
H the time being 10:15 I'd like to open
the hearing for House Bill
779 and I'd like to ask representative
Bixby to introduce this and once he's
done introducing it to please come and
take a
seat thank you madam chair for the
record our representative Peter Bixby
from do Strafford 13 uh this bill is uh
was uh submitted by representative veral
and it is for allowing the sale of
rabbit meat in interest interstate
commerce and uh what the bill does
roughly is uh currently we have a uh
provision in state law that allows uh a
uh someone who's raising rabbits to sell
up to a th000 rabbits to restaurants if
they have taken a uh particular training
course to allow to um help them do that
safely uh what this would do is allow uh
the meat from un uh from uninspected
Rabbits to also be sold um at uh a Farm
Stand
um
uh I believe also okay
so
um represented big it's it's all right
so it's in the bill and so in any case
this would this would allow um uh it to
also be sold in interstate commerce and
uh we can have more discussion of what's
involved in that once we have someone
who knows it
better thank you very much for
introducing the bill representative
wheeler did you want to take your
seat I no he's just introducing the bill
sorry
Jasper good morning Madame chairman
members of the committee I am Sean
Jasper commissioner of the Department of
Agriculture markets and food uh I'm here
just with some concerns about the
language in the bill I leave it to uh
HHS to talk to whether this is uh
permitted my reading is that under
federal law it is is because it's a
non-amenable
species um so my my issues are are
really technical uh and I'm here because
it does cover a section of law which is
under the Department of Agriculture
While most of this is under uh under HHS
but I will point out the consist
inconsistencies and problems I've seen
um much of what is being proposed in
RSA 143
a20a is already stated in 143
a20 um the definition of uninspected
meat is currently defined in 143 A14
which covers both poultry and rabbits is
different than what is proposed in
143a 20a which covers only rabbits so
you have uh a problem there in having
rabbits in two places with a different
uh definition the labeling requirements
for the purchase of uninspected poultry
and r by licensed restaurants in 143 a15
is slightly different from what is being
proposed in
143a 20a Roman 1 2 and 3 I happen to
like what's in there but it is different
and I think that the new section is
intended to cover both sales to
Consumers and sales to restaurant but if
you go back to what's specific to
restaurants you have that inconsistency
um
and RSA 2 uh 472
A5 which is the part that I'm concerned
about does not refer to rabbits and it's
difficult to understand how a section
that is not specific to the current
species could be applied to
rabbits um and and frankly I just I
don't think this belongs at all um for
instance if you use strictly and just
red rabbits into what is is there now
you would be saying that you could only
sell rabbit meat from September 1st to
April 30th I do not believe that is the
intent this section of law also imposes
regulations that are not currently
required when rabbit meat is sold to
restaurants but now it would apparently
apply to all of that and that has to do
with Veterinary Services lab work uh and
all of that um I would suggest that if
you think the the requirements need to
be greater than what are there just
expanding the sales to Consumers that a
new section of law be used please don't
try to use 472a I just don't think it it
works at
all and that concludes my testimony uh
representative Bixby so is 472a the one
the section that deals with cids and
bison correct okay so we're and and so
so
basically uh that bit about the the time
frame which is what October to April yes
uh that's so that uh the animal will
cool down when when it's after it's been
slaughtered which is an issue with
something as big as a bison but perhaps
not with a rabbit yeah and there there
are just so many requirements there and
it just does not seem to be something
that should be applied to rabbits at all
so it sounds like uh not impose to the
principle of this bill you just think
that there have been some mistakes made
in the drafting that can be re repaired
by an amendment that focuses just on
rabbits I I think so and also looking
carefully at at a20 as it exists in a20a
and removing the inconsistencies follow
up follow up okay so for the sales to
restaurants uh we have a uh a training
course for safe handling that um
is offered through Co Cooperative
Extension I I haven't read this
thoroughly but my sense it looked like
that wasn't required for the sale to um
uh the on Farm sales that are allowed in
this so would you think that that
training program would be appropriate to
add to this yes if it doesn't cover it
and unfortunately I've been little busy
and I dug down into some of the things
and didn't quite have enough time to get
to that um but that certainly should be
a requirement is you know yesterday my
testimony uh there was a lot I had a lot
of concern about um that type of issue
so certainly I think that um that should
be continued and uh those courses should
be required and and one more followup
this is this is sort of definitional for
those of the the members on the
committee who haven't been here forever
and ever just a clarification that a
non-amendable species is something that
is not
currently uh under the jurisdiction of
of the USDA that's that's correct and
that you know goes back to when these
species were not commonly used as as
meat in in Commerce Maybe by hunters but
um not specifically here and that's you
know that's fine but um yes that is what
it is uh I also would just for let you
know and I was just trying to quickly
pull it up and I looked at it a couple
minutes ago we currently have um 45 I
believe don't hold me to that number
exactly 45 people in the state of New
Hampshire
who are registered as rabbit producers
and who are current on their U uh
coursework with through Cooperative
Extension on this thank you for those
numbers and just uh to reiterate I had
spoken to the prime sponsor about the uh
training that is already required and he
he was very amenable uh to that being
added to this bill so uh to the amenable
species to the non- amenda bles yes um
representative wheeler thank you madam
chair thank you commissioner speaker
commissioner for taking my question yes
um I'm just wondering can would you be
able to send the committee the list of
the the notes that you have there so we
can get the rsa's correct I can do that
I just noticed I'd made one mistake and
did a two in instead of a four but I'll
correct that here and that's what I was
worried about doing I was trying to
write them as you set them by yeah I I
will give you you uh I've only got one
copy but I'd be glad to uh to pass it
along thank you Mr Speaker any other
questions for the commissioner thank you
very much for being here right my
pleasure thank
you I'd like to call Erica Davis and
Michelle Roberge from the Department of
good Mo good morning members of the
committee for the record my name is
Michelle robers I'm the bureau chief for
public health protection within the
division of Public Health Services at
the Department of Health and Human
Services and with me this morning is
Erica Davis and she's the food
protection section administrator within
the division of Public Health Services
um we have some testimony to share with
you and you should have written copies
of it as as well good morning members of
the committee thank you for the
opportunity to speak today on HB
779 and a a lot of what had commissioner
Jasper mentioned are some of our
concerns as well um currently rabbit
meat is allowed to be sold to
restaurants um according to the
provisions of 143a 14 through 143
a16 it does require that rabbit
producers have an educational course and
Agriculture with this bill it would
create a new
section allowing for the expansion of
rabbit meat to be sold at the farm a
Farm Stand or a farmers's
market it also includes restaurants in
this new section so effectively this
would create two different regulations
one only speaking to rabbits being so to
restaurants the second
including um Safe Handling instructions
labeling and also um Provisions for
rabbits being sold to restaurants what's
currently in statute now requires the
education and requires registration
whereas this new subdivision does not
speak to the educational requirements um
or the registration with Department of
Agriculture so in turn this just it it
makes the
to
um the new statute and the old statute a
bit
confusing uh we would recommend that if
this was to move forward that the
educational and registration
requirements be added to um the
me any questions from the committee
represent Bixby so uh you are
essentially uh don't see any problems
with extending the sale of rabbits to um
Farm Stand to at Farm stands and at uh
farmers markets by the producer but just
making sure but we just need to make
sure that it doesn't um screw up current
law and that it has the same protections
law as long as it has the educational
requirements and and the registration
requirements yes we would we agree with
that
any other questions seeing none thank
you very much thank you uh
representative Skelly could you grab the
blue sheet for me for HB
okay the clerk has made the
note um let's see what we have
here online uh we have 47 in support two
opposed and on the blue sheet we have uh
one person in
support seeing that I'm going to close
you I think um this probably should go
to this probably should go to the um
either the food or the animal
subcommittee to get
um amended or or actually maybe we don't
need to do it with the committee do you
um maybe we can just one of us can
volunteer representative Bixby are you
volunteering I would volunteer to to fix
the language on this thank you very much
the other amendment that I'm doing is
the one that for which
um
Addie I'm blanking her last yeah um uh
me
e
okay um it is uh 11 o'clock and I'd like
to reconvene our um work session from
this
morning
um so if our members can take their
seats and uh we were discussing
55 and uh we we determined that that was
going to go to the food safety
subcommittee comme I want to skip uh
over to uh HB
396 uh as uh representative ktoa has to
leave a little early and um she has some
additional information that she would
like to provide the committee with so uh
let me turn this over to representative
ktoa uh regarding comments on HB 396
exempting meat and meat food products
slaughtered and prepared in the state
for sale in state from certain
inspections go ahead representative com
uh thank you representative and thank
you for all the committee members that
stayed to the end I did uh listen uh
online while the testimony was going but
I did have an appointment I needed to
get to
um so as I sat and listened and
understand that it is against federal
law
currently um and as we also heard that
at the federal level for the last eight
years they've been trying to get this
changed and
we heard
from people that are both for and
against
this there was one person that
testified that has a custom meat shop
that is allowed to sell cuts of meat
because their animal the amenable
species is slaughtered at a USDA
facility I just handed out something
that is on the Department of Health and
Human Services uh site on who is allowed
to sell cuts of
meat
um
and the thing is is custom please
there's plenty a custom
exempt um can only sell quarter half or
whole
animal and I've read this here
and nowhere on this sheet does it say
that if an animal is slotted at a c at a
USDA facility that a then custom Meat
Shop can then sell cuts of
meat and I do believe that a lot of the
people do not realize that that is can
be done because we heard everything
about how it had to be slotted and
processed at a USDA facility
but then she spoke about how she is not
a USDA facility but can sell cuts and
represented Bixby has something he wants
to say Madam chair representative Bixby
yes so um when we H uh the last go round
of study committees on um uh which you I
believe you organized that and we had
Thomas cero from the USDA here and he
laid out a number of different ways that
uh you you could get
exemptions and the there are and one of
those exemptions is basically what uh
Miss Brady is doing at her shop uh where
it is USDA slaughtered meat but uh there
is an exemption for doing the cutting up
that you can get through the uh uh
through the USDA if you are working in
in a state inspected facility uh so
that's what she's got there so
representative um Bixby um
but don't you think that on the Health
and Human Services sheet that they
should have that listed that if you get
that done then this is how then if
you're State inspected then you can do
that we have USDA inspected facilities
that I don't know if they actually
realize that they can do that and I
think that really needs to be laid out
plainly uh in in in law or in a sheet
that this handout was directly from
uh the website yeah I would agree that I
would agree that we that it would make
sense to make sure that uh that uh DHHS
is aware of all the possibilities that
are available through USDA for
exemptions and that they are all covered
on the website okay representative
Penza um thank you madam chair uh I
agree so um her testimony which she had
repeated um because
the committee uh that stayed and um we
were asking questions she she probably
repeated this I would say at least two
possibly three times in explaining her
um her facility how it was State not
USDA um and and in a sense like
exemption carv out um but it was you
know I think we were all kind of
surprised so I believe that the way to
handle this besides of course
um the documents from the agency
definitely have to be reflective of all
the options that are available for our
um for our meat producers but um you
know is there a possibility that we can
take you know this itl bill now looks a
little bit different in a sense where we
can
State all of the options that are
available um in statute current ly for
um for our Farmers is that something
that we can do I I would actually
suggest that we retain the bill as
opposed to itl it because number one I
don't know what's going to happen from
the federal level uh in so far as
passing the prime act or if they take
any other actions through the
USDA and um my preference would be then
to retain the bill as opposed to it Ling
it um and we can have further
conversations next year about um what to
do but absolutely uh any kind of
documents uh that Department of Health
and Human Services has regarding how you
can get exemptions how where whatever
the rules are need to be complete yeah
representative ktoa and then you can
reply uh thank thank you madam chair for
that and I would appreciate if we could
retain this bill but I also believe that
in listen to the discussion that an HCR
sending a strong message um and
including the Senate on that message uh
would be more power you know to go to
Congress uh would be a wonderful uh
thing for us to do as a state because
and representative Bixby mentioned
roving inspectors and you know we've
heard the term but the unfortunately in
the discussions with that is that is
used mostly in the West
um where it makes more sense it doesn't
make a lot of sense here in the
Northeast so it's I don't I think it's
kind of cost prohibitive at this time
for those
inspectors um but we need to figure
something
out if the federal government isn't
going to work to make small farms viable
and be able to sell to their customers
what the customers
want we need there needs to be a way
because you can sell
roadkill you can cut up roadkill and
give that you can non- amenable species
rabbit and poultry but amendable
species you know why why the carot
fermentable I guess is my
question represent poent and then
Bixby yeah I um thank you madam share
yeah I agree I was really kind of all of
this was a a huge uh Awakening of just
some stuff and I know um representative
H Haskins felt the same way um I believe
that first and foremost uh and I think
this is a this is a golden nugget so
what we've just discovered and what we
heard from um from Miss batty which she
I I believe she's the president of the
Farm Bureau I mean that's
fantastic um we should be getting this
out and I mean
DHHS can get it out we could have that
come through uh commissioner Jasper and
so this could go out to every single
farmer right now as a as a notice that
is wanting to that has you know meat
wants to produce whatever with cuts um I
I think it's a fantastic way right now
that we can tell them hey this is the
steps that you can take um to to be able
to uh apply for this type of uh
exemption love it that's perfect and and
then in the meantime I love sending the
message to the federal delegation I
think that's um I think that's great and
I would love um representative Bixby it
would be great if you can as the ranking
member um you know rally up all the team
on your side and we we send a really
powerful message how that we support uh
this for New Hampshire and we'd like
something to be done um and that would
be great if it goes on to the Senate
then we can have that too so I think
that we have a lot of things and I want
I want the bill retained as well in the
meantime while we're you know kind of
all the tools in the toolbox so yeah I
would um I would suggest that um
representative kto perhaps also
representative Bixby um work with Farm
Bureau to get um an HCR put together
that we can uh bring to the house floor
uh suspend the rules and present and so
if you can work on that together that
would be great represent viby um so
there are there were a couple of
different options in terms of
resolutions uh house resolution is just
the house we don't it it doesn't get
either the weight of the Senate behind
it or the potential impediment of the
senate in front of it uh and uh if we
can get I think that it would be a more
powerful message if we can do a joint
resolution and get the Senate to join us
on that and I I talked to Howard Pearl
yesterday um and he
was not entirely convinced but he was
not entirely opposed so uh so I think
that yes Senator inis is also so um so I
I think maybe maybe we should um touch
base with senator inis in terms of uh
being the Mover behind that in the
Senate but I think that if the Senate
suspends their rules and puts in a uh a
um joint
resolution that would be better than if
we just do a house resolution if the
Senate if we can't get the Senate to to
to do that then uh I think it would be
very straightforward to propose a rule
suspension and I think that it would be
very easy to get Judy and me and Alexis
and Jason all to be sponsors on that on
on that motion and uh and that would
probably give us a pretty solid vote on
it uh and uh and at that point we could
do a a house resolution um and I think
that we' need to do the rules suspension
one week and then we could draft it and
have it ready for the next week okay
yeah and I definitely I I I agree with
the Senate piece I think it's a a bigger
punch and I and I bigger message um I I
think that if you know just from his
testimony I think Senator inis would
would be perfect to lead that charge and
um in the Senate so okay so if if
representative Bixby and comat and Penza
if you want um Al together work with the
the two people in the Senate to get that
done um and I I'll certainly work with
uh house
leadership uh to uh put that in the
agenda for whatever house session
upcoming um we can we can get the
resolution part done um I
I so so the plan would be then to retain
the bill and also to make sure that um
these rules or this sheet this sheet is
um somehow made public or uh I I pulled
it right off the uh internet so okay
right from it's a PDF you're finding
that there's some aspect of it that is
not complete well it doesn't list here
that the USDA exemption exists about the
state inspected facility okay okay so um
perhaps you can draft some language to
add to this and we can um request uh
DHHS to include it on their on their
information thank you madam chair okay
any any other comment or question I just
wanted to I didn't weigh in on the um go
we in retaining the bill but I think
that makes sense okay good good uh yeah
representative Scully hi um let me Begin
by saying I will vote to retain the bill
okay so which is now I did have a
question because one of the and again
I'm new to this whole issue of meat
processing so um it did seem like one of
the great concerns was having uh
adequate inspection and oversight here
um the fact that the small local render
Slaughter folks didn't have that um is
it does it make sense to have almost an
intermediate step and this may be need
to be done at the federal level to have
a licensing program so we could create
um licensed inspectors who could go to
these facilities and provide some level
of oversight to deal with some of the
concerns people have about making sure
things are being done correctly
represent K thank you madam chair um
there are
as Miss Brady said she is a state
inspected facility so there are state
inspections but a lot of uh uh they're
going to speak to that in a minute uh
they're raising their hand but um a lot
of the custom Meat Shops are USDA
inspected and the difference between a
USDA inspected and a USDA approved
facility is having an inspector on
site that is the difference but they are
inspected
yearly if they're USDA inspected
facility um so we already have you know
there's already that cob out there where
and if you go into these USDA inspected
facilities um a lot of these custom meat
shops that that have taken that step
or they're
spotless um you know having in the past
I no longer raise animals but having
done the pork and the beef
um I can tell you you know in going both
to USDA and
custom I would prefer the
custom
um and also when they talked about
stress on the
animals of traveling you know to get
slotted it does make a difference in the
meat and it really does stress out the
animals and I don't know if you've ever
been stressed out but everything
tightens up on you you um so you're
taking these animals away from their
home where they're raised and love and
cared for you know even though they're
were they're going to be used for meat
um and you're you're you're putting in a
huge amount of stress on it on them um
for the non-amenable species and I know
representative Bixby will correct me if
I'm wrong um I believe we had it so that
they could be slotted on property um um
as long as a licensed veterinarian was
there is that correct representative
Bixby there there are um a handful of
non-edible species that uh are we have a
a procedure set up for uh doing on Farm
Slaughter and
um that that would be bison and uh elk
and Red Deer uh I think those are the
three that are current uh that are
currently allowed uh not white tail deer
but the Red Deer is not native to New
Hampshire it is uh and they're kept in
um enclosures that are you know there
are uh fishing game rules for how the
enclosures need to be kept that are
quite thorough uh and so the idea is
that the elk and the deer don't mix with
the native populations and that reduces
the possibility of disease transfer uh
but uh but we do have a a uh an on Farm
Slaughter uh procedure laid out for that
that does involve the an uh Veterinary
inspection and uh and uh a number of you
basically what it takes to make a uh hum
Humane and sanitary Slaughter and then
Provisions in terms of how the meat
needs to be treated post Slaughter in
order to make in order to make sure sure
that it stays
good okay uh so just a question so is
that for personal consumption or does
that allow the sale to restaurants and
that allows uh sales
to it allows sales interstate and I
forget the exact you know whether there
are further restrictions on where
interest state that can be I think you
can actually I think you can sell that
through
a I'm not actually I'm not I'm not going
to go I don't remember what the details
in terms of sales is but it uh that I
think it's direct I think that it's
direct to Consumer sales rather than
um uh non
USDA yeah you're talking about like yeah
seen that okay so okay so so then then I
uh so I don't as I said I don't remember
exactly what
iser but I've seen um like
local sorry I haven't seen it at like a
grocery store level but I've seen it at
like a local you know um like that place
in um that place in hookit that I talked
about that sells local they have they
had deer meat and stuff like that so
delicatess huh delicatess no it's not a
delicatessen it's it's a I don't know
kind of like a farm stand that has a lot
of local stuff they sell honey and maple
syrup and and pies and but they have
they have pork and meats and stuff like
that there too all right thank you
okay any any other
discussion about HP 396 so what I have
that uh the plan for that bill is uh to
retain it first of all um secondly to
work on a a joint resolution between the
house and the Senate uh to come up with
some wording for that resolution and
then discuss with uh house leadership
and um uh suspending the rules in an
upcoming session in order to introduce
said resolution
um working with the Senate to have that
done on their side as
well and then uh to have uh this
information posted by
DHHS uh to update on uh the other
exemptions that are seem to be lacking
in this document and I Barb you're going
to work on that right okay cool oh
anything else what oh I'm sorry go ahead
you and thanks for being here to uh to
to
collaborate good morning good morning so
I I we did sit and listen to testimony
yesterday for um the exempting the meat
products and from from what I can
understand of the woman that spoke of
her facility of North that's licensed by
us is that she is receiving USDA
slaughtered meat products back into her
facility which she is further processing
under our license so we are not
inspecting the slaughter and we're not
inspecting the meat portion of it what
we're doing is we're licensing her as a
um I apologize I don't know exactly what
she's licensed for right now but she
does have a license with us um so she's
either a commercial facility or a retail
facility that is taking that USDA
slaughtered Meats cutting it further and
selling it direct to her
consumers okay yeah sure represent
comfortable so so she's taking so the
animal is being slotted at a USDA
facility and she's taking that back that
meat back and she can sell Cuts she can
CU she's selling direct consumer in a li
from a licensed facility okay thank you
you're
welcome
okay represent Penza you have a question
for them just real quick so um I I I
think you're brand new with the agency
correct or so I'm new I'm new to this
position oh okay I've been I've been
with um food protection for uh eight
years but I'm sure there's just a lot of
different
I'm sure this is like something that
you're not necessarily talking about all
the day all day long or whatever so is
this um are you going to be able to kind
of give a um I know in a document it
won't
necessarily um have like a you know
it'll there needs to be more information
on here about of course what Miss um uh
Miss Brady has but is there a way that
maybe in an addendum to the document
that if any of the people that testified
of course that um are wanting to they
take their animal and they have it
slaughtered and bring it back they want
to be able to have this option that she
has will can there be an addendum kind
of a a stepbystep process and who that
they would contact to be able to have
these the same option I mean I can see
that there' be several that would be
very interested in um in doing this
based upon our testimony from yesterday
we we'd be more than happy I'm not sure
which document you're referring to but
we'd be more than happy to take a look
at it and and make any adjustments I I
want to just make sure that everyone
understands that they have to come in
and get a license with the department
and there are certain terms and
conditions in which they would have to
meet in order to get that license so I'm
happy to look if there's any language in
there that needs Clarity we certainly
would be more than happy to do that and
you know we can we can put information
out about our license but it is is it
would whoever's interested in pursuing
that would need to follow those
requirements and get a license and um so
happy to happy to look at the I'm not
sure which document you're referring to
but happy to look at that could I have a
followup sure can thanks Madam chair do
you off the top of your head have any
idea of costs involved or or anything
off the top of your head I can't
necessarily speak to that um do you know
how much a license is a depending on the
facility our licenses at the most
expensive our 8875 is is our highest
licensed cost $75 no no $875 oh $ 875
and and just would you know if um if
Miss Brady is that the type of license
that she had so you're not sure I'm not
sure most most facilities are not
licensed with the person's name in the
Forefront so I would need to be able to
look up her um her business her business
information when you do find that out um
what type of license she possesses could
you please let me know how many of other
facilities or people have that license
in the state I can um I don't know if
that's going to give you the best idea
because they are licensed categories so
she could be licensed as a retail food
store with one food prep area which
incorporates many different facilities
so that could be um you know a small
grocery store that has a food prep area
it could be a gas station that has a um
gotcha I get it I get it if you could
send yeah I think if you send it to
Madame chair that'd be great and then
she pushes it out to the committee I
think we'd love to see what the license
is and how it's set up and that'd be
wonderful I just just wanted to clarify
that we are still beholden to the USDA
rules sure um by the USDA and by the FDA
Federal food code so when uh which is
what we've adopted as our as our code
for for inspection and it would require
um in a retail licensed facility that
the product is either USDA meat product
or that has a state equivalent um
inspection to go along with that meat to
be served and sold in a licensed ref
retail
facility and if I just may add and the
Department of Health and Human Services
doesn't oversee a meat inspection
program so there you know New Hampshire
doesn't have a state equivalent program
that would fall more under the
Department of Agriculture I think there
is something in Statue but I don't think
there's anything that supports the
program so that doesn't fall to the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services I just wanted to make that
clear to the committee that would fall
more likely any kind of state program
Meat Inspection program would fall more
towards Department of Agriculture
represent com talk
uh thank you madam chair and thank you
for being here so I guess the disconnect
and and I I I think I'm still hearing
the
disconnect is you keep saying USDA
approved but she's only doing USDA
Slaughter and then she's bringing that
back to her retail facility to cut up
and sell cuts of meat and also use those
cuts and those products in prepared
foods
so I'm just trying to figure out how we
go from a USDA slotted to a retail
facility that can sell cuts when you
keep when everything else that we've
heard says that to be USDA approved it
has to be also processed at a USDA
facility I'm I'm I'm not see I'm I'm I'm
there's a disconnect somewhere and I'm
trying to find out where that disconnect
is
so there are also um let me see how I
can a grocery store could essentially do
the same thing get a larger cut of USDA
inspected meat products and cut it
further and sell it direct to to the
consumer and they're inspected and they
have a license with and they have a
license with food protection with
Department of uh Health and Human
Services to be a re retail food
establishment
so it's no different they can't take a
custom cut right they couldn't go
through a custom cut and then further
cut it they have to go to a USDA
processing facility and get a large cut
and then once they have a food
protection license with us they can
further cut that but again the USDA side
of it is not doesn't fall within it's a
requirement but it doesn't fall within
DHHS that those rules are separate
that's Federal and then state state
agriculture thank you okay represent
Penza
um what you just said though is is in
the meantime where we're waiting for
things to change because I understand
that we're going to you know we're
following we're going to have to follow
federal law and state law and all of
those types of things this is this could
be a pathway for you know maybe a dozen
different type producers to do exactly
that because they're in a sense they're
some of them are doing everything right
now
um that
um they're doing all this whole process
where they're they're taking their
animal they're having it slaughtered and
they're bringing it back but they are
not further you know they are selling
half quarter whatever but um what she's
doing uh Miss Brady she wants to be able
to slaughter she doesn't want to have
have to take it anymore she was clear
about that so we're not going to solve
that here but what can be solved which I
actually think could provide relief to
so many of the people that came here to
testify is what she does have and uh and
I think that would be fantastic um so I
just hope that we can make this a nice
smooth process and um I'm really excited
for a lot of people that have been maybe
frustrated um with certain things that
are happening um you know within their
business sure the one thing I'll just
note is some of the testimony that I
heard yesterday was the was around uh
the need to take you know the
frustration around getting uh a spot if
you will at a USDA facility and I just
want to make the
committee understand that what you know
what a license through us to process
doesn't alleviate the need to still go
through a USDA so that doesn't really
address the concern about sort of that
bottleneck if you will it's still a
requirement we understand that and I I
would love for the committee to try and
find out ways in which we
can help establish more USDA facilities
Slaughter facilities in the state I mean
I know I know that through testimony we
heard some people say it's just way too
expensive for me to become a USDA
inspector Ed facility um and and I
wonder if you know there's some some
kind of way in which a fund can be set
up or some funds can be granted or
whatever to help local farmers uh you
know afford that or subsidize that piece
I don't know I'm just dreaming here
represent
Bixby so
um I have here a um explanation from the
USDA about the excuse me um retail
Restaurant Central Kitchen exemption
which I believe is probably what uh Miss
Brady is operating under uh so
operations traditionally and usually
conducted at retail stores restaurants
and Retail type establishments that
offer meat and meat food products for
sale or service to household consumers
generally are exempt from mandatory
inspection only inspected and passed
meat and meat food food products those
bearing a mark of inspection may be used
in the preparation of products sold
including meals at retail stores or
restaurants so um what that when it says
U the the bearing the mark of inspection
that would either be a USDA inspection
Mark or if there was a state inspection
program uh then that state inspection
program Mark so
uh so basically if you're operating
uh if you have an operation where you
sell meat at retail you can take uh meat
that has been uh slaughtered with a USDA
inspection and then process it further
in your operation to sell it at retail
yeah yeah is can you um get a copy of
that and send it to me or send me the
link of where that is to send it to the
committee I'll send it to okay good
enough thanks represent uh come thank
you madam chair
and so I'm listening and you know we've
heard testimony about USDA facilities
non USDA facilities I'm wondering and as
an option that you have just a USDA
slaughter house not somewhere where they
actually process meat but just
Slaughter um I think might be a middle
ground and someone may be willing to do
that I also believe
that the bottleneck at these USDA
facilities is not so much the slaughter
of the animals as it's the hanging space
and their freezers so if someone was
able to bring animals to have them
slaughtered on site um to the usdaa
facility they would then be taking them
back with them at the same time so they
wouldn't need to be hanging because they
would have their own coolers and things
to that effect so I I don't think that
the bottleneck that we're seeing now uh
would prevent additional Slaughter it's
all about the hanging
space interesting point representative
Penza um thank you madam chair
so when um representative Bixby was
speaking I was thinking exactly what
representative compto was so think about
this business idea representative
wheeler we could we could get into
business together because you look very
interested in this subject so we could
have literally like a rolling
slaughterhouse like literally it's a big
huge you know roll you know on a I don't
know if you want to call it a you kill
them we chill them yeah is that it it's
it's literally fantastic I
mean you know these people drive these
campers around I'm serious so we could
literally handle new hand share I I'm
not I can't but I think it's a fantastic
business model and I I I'm going to
invest in it so I'm totally serious is
what do you think course we have the
vegan in the back of the room who's just
horrified of the whole thing I know I
know I'm so not an animal killer but I I
I just really feel feel that it is oh my
gosh what a business model and and dhss
they look at look it they're loving it
so represent Bixby so um I have asked
about that model that you're talking
about I believe that Rob Johnson might
know about it a bit about it too um but
um I have asked you know why can't we
have mobile Slaughter fac facilities in
New Hampshire and uh and part of the
answer is it would be totally legal and
the other part of the answer is that
this is something that they do out west
and part of the challenge is that the
cost per Slaughter goes up
substantially so if you're taking your
mobile Slaughter facility to a ranch
that has you know several hundred head
and you're Pro and you're doing them all
there and then moving on to you know
moving on to the next one then that
becomes you know you can do it at a at a
price per animal that will make the meat
affordable if you're doing it if you're
going from one Farm to another Farm
where they each have like three or four
animals that need to be slaughtered it
suddenly the per animal price just
Skyrock and that's and people have I
think people have looked at the
potential of this and said I don't think
we can afford to do this I mean I would
love if someone would you know figure
out a way that they could afford to do
it uh it is a known technology but I'm
not sure but I think the impediment is
actually the business the I I think
there are business impediments to it
that um we can't legislate and I don't
but we might not get someone to say oh
I'm going to to lose $100,000 a year so
I can have good slaughtered meat in New
Hampshire but but that model is not
illegal to do here in New Hampshire oh
that model is entirely legal it is just
you need to get someone who either can
figure out a way to make it sufficiently
efficient that they'll be able to set
that the meat can be sold at a
reasonable price or uh well I guess
that's the question you you you need to
get someone who can
uh can figure out how to do it at a
price point that's workable and that's
and that's an an impediment that we have
you know with a lot of what we're doing
a lot of the issue is not that we have
that there's a legal impediment to
having a federally inspected uh uh
Slaughter location it is that doing that
is it it's a difficult business
proposition which means that people
aren't just jumping in to do it correct
okay any other discussion on this
bill okay um I think we we uh have a
plan for this and
uh we can move on to talk about I know
we discussed the um freeze-dried foods
HB
505 um and that is going to be discussed
by the Food Safety Committee so I'll
have to set up a time for us to meet
meet um and then we can talk about HP
642 which is sort of a companion bill to
the freeze-dried foods which was um the
dehydrated meat or the jerky bill with
uh with the committee we can discuss
that now too if you want anybody had
comments about HB 642 I know I did have
an intention to uh make some changes to
that bill already because uh number one
of the drafting error on um line five on
page
one uh which the drafter put in the
words freeze dried which is not what
this is about this is about dehydrated
food and
um also I wanted to to include a
um uh a part section uh having to do
with limiting the amount of uh
dehydrated meat that can be produced on
a weekly
uh or daily b or so produced on a weekly
basis sold on a daily basis that uh was
was uh inadvertently left out of the
draft so uh any other comments or
questions about um this particular
Bill representative Bixby okay so this
is limited to a meat producer
distributor who has a licensed to sell
USDA inspected meat right yes
so um and and and the the constituent
who asked me to present this bill um he
does have a
USDA you know inspected well producer
distributor
license so he said you know I he he he
raises livestock gets them
um uh slaughtered and cut up whatever
for uh for his farm and then he he
brings that back okay so he has so um
both the slaughtering and
the um and the cutting up of cutting it
up into uh retail Cuts is done off
offsite I believe so I I would have to
um confirm that with him but I think
that that's the case so he does so
basically he has a retail setup where he
likes has freezer freezer and stuff yes
and but he doesn't have a commercial
kitchen or anything like it correct okay
um
so
[Music]
um yeah
I I'm I'm
I'm I'm wondering
whether uh this is the best way to best
place in statute to to do this and
whether this is the best way to do it um
but um I think this I think it might
make sense for this to go to the
subcommittee also yeah we'll discuss
this as well and I think that um I think
that we probably want to get food
Protective Services there to help us out
figuring out what the best way to have
this because it looks like there's a
certain amount of process information
which might belong in rules because um
process information you there can be
changes in terms of recommendations from
from the FDA in terms of process that
could be might and they might be just
minor tweaks but it's a minor tweak that
is easier to do in rules than like
turning it putting in a whole new bill
so some of this might not make sense to
put in statute uh and uh but I there's
also uh but making sure that the process
mechanism is properly reviewed on I
think is important the body of all of
this you know about you know sanitation
and uh Fahrenheit that you have to steam
or roast the meat or um you know the
dehydrated meat process and so forth I
took that totally from the USDA website
okay which which I think makes sense
yeah and this is exactly the procedure
that uh the the um my constituent
follows as well okay so you know he says
if you do it this way there's there's no
risk at all for any kind of food illness
so I think the the the challenge here is
is not you know I I think my sense is
that given the amount of um safeguards
you have in in the bill it does you know
the concept works it makes sense it's
just a matter of how to put that into
Statute in a way that will make it um
appropriately operable okay and I think
that getting some help from food
protector services on that would would
be useful uh and it look like you wanted
to jump
in come on
up should represent
Penza just thinking from all of our
previous conversation would because this
person is already USDA certified right
um or a facility they're already doing
Cuts in retail
would this kind of apply in a sense
could they have this in a sense
exemption or no because it's like a a
different way that they're processing it
because they're doing something else
further with the meat do you know what
I'm saying no
okay I think I understand what you're
saying and the the question is INS the
question is so is there is their current
level inspe of inspection sufficient to
allow them to do this and um uh and you
know or is is there something that has
to do with their the way they are
processing that would require a separate
or different level of inspection and I
think that's and figuring out how to do
that appropriately in statute and Rule
is something that we need to uh have
some help with some experts on and you
know and I to be fair I had hoped that
he would have come yesterday to testify
or at least Supply us with uh written
testimony I guess he's been real busy
with his farm and and his livestock um
but I would like to have him come and
and explain to us or at least to the
subcommittee um exactly what his
procedures are how he's licensed and uh
and what he does um it's just that right
now uh according to statute he doesn't
have the ability to uh dehydrate any of
his meat um what he does is just for f
friends and family um he would really
like to be able to sell it to the public
and the public would really like to buy
it from him and that's where the problem
is or the issue so representative Bixby
oh I'm sorry go ahead and I would just
like to point out so as we testified
yesterday the concern around this is the
fact that it's currently it's under the
homestead exempt so it doesn't require a
license from us they can just do it we
wouldn't be there doing the inspection
and I just want to point out what we
just talked about with 390 House Bill
396 as a is a person that has a us you
know takes their meat has it slaughtered
at a USDA facility brings it back in and
has a license with us to process that
meat and I think that's the Department's
biggest concern is that currently this
dehy the way this the bill is written is
this exempt this would allow them to be
license exempt so there would be no
license from the Health and Human
Service is no inspection and that's
concerning to the department and that's
what our testimony is about is is to say
per you know perhaps it's better to have
a license with us and and it's done at a
at a at a facility at a commercial
facility um similar to um the woman that
testified yesterday for 396
so and I so currently just just so you
know so if if this gentleman wanted to
take his USDA flattered meat and to make
the jerky there is a PA a licensed
pathway forward for him to have um a a
retail or commercial facility where he
could further process um further process
the meat into so what would be required
for him because what I understood from
him would be that he would have to
invest in getting a commercial kitchen
three Bay sink have you know a whole
bunch of other stuff and he he said to
me that that was cost prohibitive for
him and and that is the barrier so for
him at this point licensing would
require those things yeah um and we
would ask for a process review and to
have a plan in place to make sure that
all those dehydrated safety parameters
would be
met and I and if I just add um I know
during the summer when we met and talked
about various
um uh food processes including
dehydration and and freeze drying there
was a a woman who who came and spoke to
us and she runs a business where she
rents out commerci space so and and I
know that there's at least one possibly
more so that is also an option while
it's not you know it doesn't
meet uh you know to be able to do it in
their home um but there is a step in
between going from a full-on commercial
kitchen yourself to renting some space
in a commercial K in a commercial
kitchen that is license so they can go
and do their their thing but they
wouldn't have to do the full investment
at their property or there or buy a you
know brick and B brick and mortar space
to have a commercial grade kitchen so
there is some some space in there yeah
but let's face it I mean then you have
to bring your dehydrators over there and
you there has to be a time where you
need to keep an eye on it that you make
sure that you know that everything is
running the way and it's really it's not
practical to do it that way to to be
able yes there are commercial kitchens
you can rent the space you can rent the
time but to do a process like this
through that
mechanism it's just not practical
practical or workable and it may even be
very expensive for the producer too so
you know it's just a whole lot easier if
they are um able to do this in their in
their own space that's all we're looking
at uh representative wheeler
just to add on to what you said Madam
chair and the renting of a space or
something along those lines I mean these
businesses are not operating at huge
profit margins you know they don't
necessarily have the capital to be able
to go out and rent a space in their
business which is which is why he
approached me and said you know I'd
really like to be able to do this
without having to establish an entire
commercial kitchen to do
it so represent Bixby yeah so one
possibility I'm envisioning is um
looking at whether there is a a sort of
scaled down version of a commercial
kitchen that one could set up just for
dehydrating and freeze drying operations
that wouldn't have as as large an
overhead cost as as a as a fullscale
commercial kitchen yes I wonder would
DHHS have any kind of recommendations as
to
a minimal
commercial kitchen operation that
wouldn't be like
fullscale three Bay sink uh you know
separate um bathroom facilities and
seating for so many people or whatever I
don't know I mean there's a there's a
lot and it's a huge investment for many
people and that's the barrier that's the
thing that's really getting everybody um
wanting to not get these Homestead
licenses is because it it's it's just
such a
hassle and when you want to do something
fairly uh you know simple like freeze
drying or or
dehydrating even even you know people
have complained to me oh I need to have
a whole commercial kitchen if I want to
sell cut up apples or if I want to cut
up an onion and put it on this hot dog
that I'm selling you know I need a whole
commercial kitchen to do that and it
just it's sort of of goes against um
whatever common sense I don't know but
just
saying and I think it comes back to
looking at you know for Homestead food
operations that do um nonp potentially
hazardous foods absolutely like there
are when and it's currently allowed it's
when we move to potentially hazardous
foods and that's when the risk to the
public goes up and that's when you're
going to hear our concern so it's not so
much the non-p potentially hazardous
foods that's allowed and um you know we
don't we see that as a very low risk
it's when we move from allowing exempt
homesteads or Homestead operations to
start processing potentially hazardous
foods without lure um that's when risk
to the public goes up and that's when we
processes any other questions or
comments representative guber uh thank
you very much um I'm doing more
listening than talking but it seems to
me that uh we have a scaling issue here
where we're trying to support homesteads
where they could do things that might be
hazardous food but in a very minor
Manner and um so we have like either up
here or down here and we need to think
about is there possibility without
adding significant risk to the public
that we could actually have two or three
options of semi-commercial kitchens and
so forth so that we can balance the
issue of safety I mean you never could
be at 99.99 we never get 100% but with
some of these processes they don't seem
as risky if you have good protocol so
the question is has the agency looked at
kind of different scales of commercial
kitchen for type application so that it
the need can be in line with balancing
risk versus the cost so that we could
actually promote more homesteading over
that sort of work and then and then to
your point I mean that's why I wanted to
put a limit to how much they can produce
yes I mean if you if you're sort of
restricting the amount you're
restricting the risk um right I want you
to answer his question and then
representative patens I had a question
um thank you for the question and I I
appreciate your what you're saying and
your concern the challenges around
freeze drying and dehydrating and we
talked a little bit about this in Our
Testimony yesterday is that the process
itself um really needs review by uh by
experts so the food experts and that
doesn't fall back to the department so
establishing these sort of standard if
you will standard processes that doesn't
necessarily apply to everything that you
know you're trying to either freeze dry
or or dehydrate so there could be
instances where certain processes work
for this type of food for freeze drying
but you would need to do something
different if you're TR trying something
else and that's where the challenge
comes in because the department isn't
the process Authority we aren't the ones
that look at those you know you need to
have a food chemist to really understand
what happens in a process it sounds
simple it sounds like oh I stick it in a
machine and then it comes out the
product that I want but it's more
complex than that and it does need a
more scientific uh review and and I
understand and can appreciate you know
the testimony that we heard from
producers that it's challenging and it's
um you know it's a barrier but it is
there is a reason for it you know and it
and the science is you know that's the
the true review of the science to make
sure that the end product is safe for
the public and and that's the challenge
around trying to set these standard
Provisions in in statute because they're
not all applicable across every food
product but wouldn't stipulating in in
statute that the person follow the
manufacturer recommended procedures in
using their dehydrator or their freeze
dry equipment sufficient to have that
protection so the some of the
manufacturers they give like a a a basic
they'll give the basic time and
temperature for individual products
however we know that food producers are
um are coming up with their own recipes
and their own um thicknesses of things
that they're going to have freeze-dried
or dehydrated and all of those
components go into making sure that the
freeze dryer and the dehydrator are
working the way that you want it to so
there are basic
manufacturer I'm assuming there are
basic manufacturers that if you want to
freeze dry uh a couple of blueberries
then these are the time and temperature
parameters but when you get more complex
with your recipe and your procedure
that's what the processing Authority is
going to look at to make sure that each
of your steps with your process and your
marinades and your cuts of meat or
slices of fruit are going to be
dehydrated or freeze-dried enough to
make sure that there's no risk for
growth okay representative Penza um real
quick thank you madam chair I just want
to go back to um I think what
representative guber um said and then of
course what m madame chair was alluding
to as well I think it would be fantastic
for the agency to spend some time
putting all that stuff aside dehydration
the freeze drying Meats all of that
let's just let's just talk simple in
regards with licensing so if you only
have you know uh you know uh Homestead
and then you go up to full-blown
commercial I really think there should
be steps or stages in there and I think
um and that goes based upon you know
size and and smaller versions so someone
could get into uh um could get into
putting in you know a smaller commercial
have that license have that smaller
commercial kitchen I mean we want to be
able to make it possible for people and
I can't I mean we owned a restaurant my
father was in the restaurant business
for a long time I know a lot of things
about this and I I I know that it can be
done and it it's amazing for the agency
because there's more Revenue that's
coming in from there as well it's it's
giving more options for the public so I
just there there should be there should
be steps or stages we should really
consider that and I really hope that you
guys bring that back to the powers that
be because I I think it makes sense you
know maybe there's for when someone's
going into uh commercial and it would be
a certain amount that they're producing
and all of that they get you know a
stage one license and then it goes up to
stage three or whatever it may be but I
I just I think that we can do that um we
have enough expertise and uh I just
think that it's something that you guys
should consider representative Bigby
yeah so a couple things one um is
getting back to the question of process
review uh the process that's outlined in
uh representative eron's bill is
actually drawn from the USDA so one
possibility is that uh for certain
things we could just say that the
process needs to be a process that is
established by the USDA or was it USDA
or was it uh or um was it
uh uh
FDA this I believe uh see I think I I
believe it was from the USDA that I okay
pulled that off let me just okay so food
safety and inspection yeah us F
fsis okay so uh so we could have we
could we could reference uh existing
processes that have been published by
the federal government as one allowable
way of doing it um and so I think that
and rather than having all of those
processes laid out in the statute just
have a reference to which processes uh
there are at at the federal level that
are sadly already established um the
getting um I wish that representative
pretendo were still here because the
next thing was responding to hers which
is that I think what she's suggesting
makes sense in the long run I think that
it is probably not within your the scope
of your job descriptions to do what she
suggesting but it is in the suggest in
the scope of our job descriptions to do
study committees to look at uh What uh
what different ways of setting up
statute would be to allow that uh one of
uh in a discussion I had with uh Miss
savos uh a while back uh she mentioned
that Virginia has a different way of
setting up their uh their licensing that
had does have different gradations I
think perhaps may be similar to what
representative Penza was was mentioning
so we could we could look at um we could
look at what other states have for their
licensing approach approaches to
doing uh the the food licensing at
different levels and see if there's a
model that would allow for the kind of
uh different gradation that uh that
representative penzel was mentioning
and because I I I agree that you know
the the sort of All or Nothing approach
like you you have almost nothing for the
homestead and then you have a whole lot
for anyone who's above that uh I I think
that there's there is room for some
gradation in there but I think we need
that needs more study than we can do
right now yes I think the department
would welcome that I think I think a
study committee would be would be a
great way to have you know discussions
and get information
you know maybe a process Authority can
come and and talk about what they do and
the importance of it and yes we can
explore different uh opportunities for
facilities and lure because you know
we're we're Bound by what we what we
have directly in front of us and so um I
I welcome
that representative King real quick
question um do do the current statutes
and rules preclude barter I know you can
give away and gift um you know these
things but you can't sell them can you
barter
them my my first thought is is no it's
it within your friend group or family
yes but it's food served to the
public so if it's if it's being served
or sold to the public then it falls
within um the RSA for but it wouldn't be
sold it
Bartered like if I traded traded
dehydrated meat for some eggs at a farm
stand would that be okay I think we
would probably need a legal
interpretation on that I can't speak to
that okay but yet if you serve
dehydrated meat at a soup kitchen or had
a potluck Community potluck that would
be fine there's no problem with
that yeah anyway um I am going to close
out our work session I know we didn't
discuss hb77 but we can uh it is on the
docket to discuss that um on February on
March 4th with the next time we meet
that is included in the work session on
then and and in the in the interim uh I
believe you had sent out um um a
preliminary amendment to that Bill yes
which to the committee and we everybody
has it I spent a long time on it so I
just um um I'd love feedback um if
there's a way that I can meet with
subcommittee I I'll speak with
representative gerana and and of course
representative bisy um representative
King if we ever if we get together if we
don't or however it may be but um yeah
it's because we weren't did we want to
um did we want to exec on that day or I
don't think so I think what we're going
to do is is uh we'll have a work session
on March 4th okay and uh probably the
week after we would exec this bill okay
perfect so so that'll give us some time
I mean you sent this out this morning y
so we really do need some time to go
through everything in the amendment have
everybody on the same page and
understanding what um what the fine
points are of of many of the sections of
this bill so that we are all
understanding um the very important
pieces of um a landfill sighting that we
are suggesting uh in in making changes
to current rules that have been adopted
which we all feel are lacking correct
and in every single um um I haven't
spoken with director whims but every
single um piece that he brought up in
his testimony has been addressed yeah um
the stuff that I already knew was going
to be a hindrance have been addressed um
clarifying statements are in there um
descriptions purpose yeah this is Soup
To Nuts I didn't sleep last night to
finish it up so no no and we appreciate
I appreciate the work on there and I did
I sort of perused it be before uh when I
had some time and uh uh I I do
appreciate the clarification on uh
drinking water aquifi and and um setback
um um footage and all that so thank you
you for your attention on that as well
as you know incorporating some of the
concerns that um director whimet had and
and pointing out to uh refine this to be
um
better so yeah so uh let's adjourn and
have lunch and come back at 1:00 and we
are going to then be
hearing uh about squirrels and
raccoons fun fun times here in
environment and agriculture thank you no
you
e
all right we're g I know we're running
late um just waiting a few more minutes
uh to see if our clerk will come to the
meeting but um I just want
to say um where we are here I just want
to wait a little bit so then we'll be
underway
yeah no no no no she's that's Vice chair
representative ktoa she won't be here
this afternoon but um our clerk is uh
so so we'll wait uh until uh two more
hi
e
okay all right we're going to get
underway um sorry for the delay um we
are going to open up the uh hearing for
which is allowing the ownership of
certain squirrels and
raccoons and here today to introduce the
bill to
us is representative Jim
Spain welcome to environment and
agriculture
committee and uh thank you pleas let us
know what what your plan what your plans
are for this thank you madam chair
members of the committee I brought
brought this bill forward um because of
the incident that happened in New York
and I wanted to make sure that uh we
don't get a black eye in the state of
New Hampshire with the same sort of bad
press um and when I looked into the
situation and found out even further
um what the situation could be and
having been a chairman on fishing game
and knowing how our re rehabilitative
Services work um I felt it was it was
something that we needed to do the bill
is very tightly
crafted to allow people to have their
pet squirrel or raccoon but put
guardrails around how they can get that
and Andor um keep it um I'll start by
showing you uh you will have all seen
the
handout um if you look at the uh the
page for pet
raccoons you can see that there are uh
19 states where they're legal
31 where they're not
legal of those two of our neighbors uh
Vermont and Rhode Island allow pet
raccoons and then if you switch over to
pet squirrels you'll see that 19 states
allow those and 31 don't and oddly
enough they're not the same 19 or 31 um
and in fact Maine and Massachusetts two
pets so it's very possible that somebody
could move here from Maine or mass or
Rhode Island or Vermont and already have
one of these
pets and then they would be having to
keep it secret in the dark not taking it
to the vet not being able to get the
care that it needs and not letting
anyone know they have it for fear the
fact that the being illegal the
authorities would come and confiscate it
it so so I crafted the bill such
that it will allow them to be
possessed they call it a companion
animal in the law but it's basically a
pet if they are able to acquire one as
an adopted animal from one of our
Rehabilitation Facilities or if they
move here with one already as a pet the
bill specifically prohibits people from
breeding them or selling them and
prohibits them from Catching Wild Ones
for their own usage as a pet
pet but one of the problems we have with
our rehabilitation
facilities and the way that the law is
now is that if we rehabilitate a raccoon
or a squirrel and it's determined that
that animal cannot survive in the wild
after
Rehabilitation the fishing game re
Rehabilitation Facilities um and I'll be
clear they're not run and owned by
fishing game but they're licensed by
fishing game as rehabilitation
facilities they have limited space so
they're faced with a predicament of they
either have to keep this as their own
pet because they're the only ones
legally allowed to keep it or they have
to euthanize it and to go through
Rehabilitation on an animal and then
face the prospect of having to now
euthanize it after all of that work to
rehabilitate it is not a situation I
want to put them into and this would
allow those facilities to find a home
for one and let it be adopted so that it
could continue living out its life
without Starving in the wild because it
can't be released to the wild or being
euthanized immediately because there's
facility there's some discussion that
the the uh State veterinarian has had
with me about whether or not there are
approved vaccines for these for rabies
but there's other states where they're
legal and other states where Veterinary
Ians are administering vaccines for
rabies um for the raccoon it's it's
almost a one for one with whatever they
use for cat vaccinations for rabies
because they're so closely related to
the cats for squirrels I don't know what
they do but we allow people to have pet
rats and those go to the vet and they
get seen and squirrels are very closely
associated with with uh the other
rodents and other things as well so I
don't think it would much of a problem
and up until about I see them in being
in a situation that we had with ferrets
here in the state some I don't know 15
20 years ago it was illegal to have
ferrets in the
state and we passed a law to allow those
to be kept as pets and many people now
have ferrets and they're kept as pets
and they're kept healthy and they are
kept
vaccinated so I don't think it would be
a problem for our veterinarians in the
state to be able to acquire and
administer an appropriate level of
vaccine um keeping them vaccinated would
be part of this bill um so that they
stay
healthy and there's another safety
measure that I've put into the bill that
says uh if you look at lines 8
[Music]
through uh well eight on I
suppose this the raccoon or gray
squirrel shall not be confiscated or
euthanized without the permission of the
that is just basically to ensure that if
a raccoon or a squirrel had bit somebody
and needed to be euthanized right away
that the owner at least had given his
permission if there's a suspect
suspicion of rabies and the fishing game
wants to or the authorities want to uh
confiscate it they can't euthanize it
without permission but they can
quarantine it and watch for symptoms and
a 30-day quarantine would show symptoms
and it would be able to you be
euthanized upon first signs or could be
symptoms and with that um I'm open to
any questions you may have okay before I
entertain questions I would like
representative wheeler and
seats and
um I I do have h a few questions with
this bill um I know the incident
happened in New York New York State
correct and I see by your map New York
state does not uh it is not legal to
possess a squirrel or raccoon and
and a squirrel or a raccoon correct
they're in the same boat we are so those
yes so those folks where those animals
were confiscated and
euthanized um they had no law to protect
no law to protect them and um both the
raccoon and and the squirrel had been
rehabilitated but were keep being kept
surreptitiously
secretly so what would prevent anybody
in New Hampshire from getting a
rehabilitator license what's involved in
that so that they could so that they
could have a squirrel or raccoon it's uh
tightly controlled by fishing game as to
who's licensed to be a re Rehabilitation
facility in the state and they handle a
wide variety of animals that are found
injured on the roadside or injured in
the field um anything from uh baby deer
that the mother's been killed uh and
they're trying to save them I had one
instance where I saved a baby deer that
was being chased by a pack of coyotes
behind my house and we got it to a
rehabilitation facility but because of
the amount of trauma that it went
through just trying to escape uh it had
a heart attack in the facility and and
ended up not being able to make it but
it can be anything from you know baby
deer to Cox to owls to there's a wide
variety of animals that they are trained
to take care of and they have to be able
to take care of them and take them in to
rehabilitate them whenever fishing game
has a need so fishing game is
probably not going to deny a a suitable
facility but they have to be able to be
qualified to provide all of the medical
necessary uh Rehabilitation Facilities
uh medications and everything else that
that would be needed for any of those
animals because I um to be honest I did
have a conversation with Dr Crawford
about it and he said to me well if you
know people want a squirrel or a raccoon
as a pet that they can easily get a
rehabilitator license and be able to
keep them it's my understanding that
those licenses are not just handed out
they have to be um medically able to
care for any of the rehabilitated
animals that are brought their way mhm
do you also know uh how much it costs
the state fishing game uh to
rehabilitate an animal like a like a
squirrel or raccoon if they find a an
injured one or a baby one or something
that that has been abandoned H how much
how much time and how much money does it
cost the state to do the rehabilitation
well that's a that's a complicated issue
because part of it falls on fishing game
to actually retrieve the animal assess
it and take it to the facility um a lot
of the facilities work off of donations
and um the amount of man hours and
medication costs and such depend
entirely on what type of Rehabilitation
is needed if you're talking about a
broken wing on a hawk um it's different
than uh raising you know a baby deer
that needed to be uh taken care of just
because its mother had died and it
needed to be old enough to be released
into the wild um if you've got an animal
with with severe injuries because it's
been hit by a car but it's
still in good enough shape that it could
be re rehabilitated it's one of those
triage things that fish and game
determines on on site is whether or not
this animal needs to be put down on site
or whether it can be re rehabilitated
that could take a lot of operations and
could be great expense as well I don't
know what portion of that falls on the
state versus what portion of that is
raised through donations and um the care
of the facility
okay and so also once a raccoon or a
squirrel is rehabilitated by fishing
game if they cannot be returned to the
Wild what do they do with them in that
instance it either has to be kept by the
facility okay or
euthanized okay so they have in essence
spent a whole lot of time in money to
rehabilitate an animal potentially that
they would have to euthanize and there's
no way to tell it not going to be able
to be returned to the wild until the
rehabilitation is complete um it can be
anything from the animal is was found so
young that it just doesn't know how to
survive on its own to it just can't hunt
anymore because of you know the the even
though the wing is fixed it it won't be
able to successfully hunt field mice if
it's a uh like a hawk or if it was a
raccoon or a squirrel it could be that
you know the the raccoon had a broken
leg and even even though it's fixed now
it won't properly be able to hunt for
food okay other questions from the
committee represent Bixby yeah I'm um a
little bit um unclear on the rabies
Provisions here so um so it does it does
provide for
vaccination uh if there is a if if it's
a rehabilitated animal it has to be
vaccinated before it's transferred to
someone um
but in
line uh line eight the raccoon or gra
scroll shall not be confiscated or
euthanized without permission of the
owner but there's not any an indication
of why that you why that confiscation
might occur and which is doesn't
although it might be you and it doesn't
actually say anything about specifically
about whether the animal has bitten
anybody right so there's certain
circumstances where they may want to
confiscate one of them might be biting
somebody and in that instance you would
want to euthanize right away so that you
could get an immediate result um for
rabies because you need to do that as
soon as possible um there's no way to do
that test currently without uh removing
the head and that requires the
euthanizing of the animal but there's
also if you look further up um one of
the qualifications for being able to
continue keeping them as a pet is to
keep them up on their vaccines if NE if
the vaccine is
required um if an owner if you look at
line five it starts with uh if an owner
of a raccoon or gray squirrel cannnot
satisfy the requirements of this
paragraph the fishing game commission
may charge them with a fine set in rules
adopted under RSA 541a and the animal
shall be examined and if necessary
vaccinated in that process it would be
confiscated to be examined and
vaccinated okay thank
you I guess there was also you there was
something about you said there was like
a quarantine period that was we didn't
specify the quarantine period because
it's it's something that could be up to
whoever the expert is that's watching
the animal and whether or not it needed
to be done immediately for a bite versus
um it's just a suspicion because they
didn't stay up on their vaccines and we
before we return it to them we want to
make sure it doesn't have that disease
but a quarantine period is a way to find
out if the animal shows signs Because by
quarantining the animal it will start to
show those uh aggravated signs of rabies
over the course of um 30 days okay
follow up follow up yes so is that quar
is there a quarantine uh provision
somewhere in law that this is connected
to or we have quarantines built into law
for importing animals when animals are
imported to the state um we have
quarantines set for um dogs that have
traveled outside of the country when
they come back into the us there's
there's a lot of different instances um
and probably scattered throughout our
rsas on on when animals get quarantined
um but it isn't something that that uh
would be unique okay so so I guess that
followup followup so so it's not unique
but it doesn't seem like there's
something that is
already uh in law that would cover this
particular instance so it seems like
that might need to be specified in the
bill it's possible I would ask the
researcher for your committee to look
into whether you've spelled that out in
another section of your um environment
and agriculture laws because I really
don't know those very
well and I did depend on the on the um L
uh the um s people to uh to to look into
all of the different areas where this
might uh touch other laws okay thank
you
so in in the say some this passes and
somebody has a pet squirrel and that pet
squirrel bites somebody what would
happen as this Law requires would that
that animal immediately be confiscated
or you'd have to have uh a permission
from the owner to do that well it the
way the law is written they would need
permission from the owner but in any
animal bite situation the owners are
usually very uh because of the liability
on the owner for if somebody does get
rabies this is usually very
accommodating in a bite situation and
that happens with dogs as as
well okay representative
Scully thank you madam chair and thank
you for coming to
testify is New Hampshire within the
habitat of the red squirrel yes we are
is there a reason why you made a
distinction and have this only applies
to gray squirrels as opposed to red red
squirrels do not adapt to um being kept
as pets very well at all they are
very
Bixby so
um I if the uh so when when you're
importing a animal from another state uh
you need to have a according to um our
RS say is you need to have a um
certificate Veterinary inspection is
that something that um is there a
reference to that for these squirrels
that might be from another state or is
that something that might need to be
added it says in here
um that the animal um if the owner of
the must be up to date on any vaccines
required if the owner of a raccoon or
gray squirrel cannot satisfy the
requirements of this paragraph Etc Etc
um so the examination and the and the
vaccination coming in from the state is
implied because of the fact that they
have to have those vaccines up to date
to keep it as a pet and if they don't
keep it up to date um so it would have
to be up to date when they bring it in
um that would otherwise it would be
confiscated examined it would get its
health certificate and its vaccinations
before being returned to the
owner okay thank you so would it seemed
to me uh line 10 to 12 if a person
relocates from a state where it is legal
to keep a raccoon or gray squirrel such
person can keep such raccoon or gray
squirrel so long as such animal is up to
date on any vaccines required should
there be some sort of um
quarantine period since they are coming
in from out of state just like any other
animals we require to have
quarantines I wouldn't object to that if
that was something the committee wanted
to add um I would maybe stipulate that
if they didn't have a current and clear
health certificate the quarantining
might be needed but if they've already
got a clear health certificate and
record coming in from the other state
where they had veterinary care I I
wouldn't see the reason for that we
don't do that with somebody's dog if
they move here with a state and they've
got their upto-date medical
records okay thank you representative
wheeler thank you madam chair thank you
Mr chairman for taking my question um I
was reading yesterday about an invasion
of gray squirrels in Europe and how
they're taking over from the red
squirrels and how it's sort of they're
fighting back and forth and things like
they do fight a lot so I'm wondering my
question is does the importation of gray
squirrels will that affect the
population of squirrels overall in New
Hampshire I mean it's kind of a silly
question but I'm hearing about these
gray squirrels being invasive in Europe
or the United Kingdom or whatever so I'm
wondering we don't have a short in the
state of gray squirrels or red squirrels
and if you remember back some 5 years
ago at this point I think we had the
squirrel apocalypse where squirrel
apocalypse yeah they were they were dead
on every roadside everywhere you went
and and what happens with the life
cycles of the gray squirrel in New
Hampshire and the red squirrel as well I
don't want to slight them uh they're
just a lot more aggressive and
territorial um which is why they fight
with the gray ones the um anytime we get
a bumper crop of acorns like we did this
last
fall the next spring they're going to
have a lot more baby squirrels and then
they're going to start getting
territorial as the season starts to go
on because they're going to want to be
mating and and carving out their own
territory so you'll have them chasing
each other into the roads which is how
we ended up with that squirrel
apocalypse we had a giant spike in
population after a big Acorn year um
they chased each other into roads and
and they got hit by
cars I don't see as uh to to complete
that thought though I don't see people
bringing them in as pets contributing to
that because one if they're kept as a
pet they probably cannot exist in the
Wild on their own uh which is why
they're being kept as a pet if they're
from a rehabilitation facility but even
if they're being kept as a pet that was
raised somewhere else they're used to
that human contact and that that human
feeding and all that other stuff they're
not going to adapt well to being
suddenly released on their own uh they
would likely be killed and eaten by a
hawk or or some something else a coyote
or or what have you because they're far
too trusting of other animals and people
um the and that that would probably
happen before they starve to death right
they would have a hard time finding
their own food but they'd probably be
eaten by something else first um these
are usually kept as indoor animals when
they're kept as pets they're not
released outside like a you'd let your
cat out um or let your dog out you know
that they're they're an indoor animal
like a like a pet rat or Geral or a
guinea pig follow representative Bixby
oh okay followup represent wheeler and
then Bixby just to say thank you for
that information and I clearly don't
know enough about squirrels but it's
also maybe an interesting allegory you
know the American squirrels taking over
the British Islands that's that's an
interesting allegory goad represent so
um just a clarification on the term
Companion Animal and I think I know what
the answer to this is but I just want to
get it out there in case people are
concerned um so a companion animal is
basically a pet yes but having that that
um label as of a companion animal
doesn't mean that you can bring it into
any like uh any venue you want uh unlike
a Serv it's not like a service an animal
where you you can you have to you can
have it with you in places where you
probably shouldn't right that companion
animal is from my understanding the way
we legally refer to a pet in our
laws and I would just like to reiterate
one of the
reasons we didn't pass the kangaroo Bill
last year was because when you have a
when you state that you have a companion
animal that also uh has bearing on if
people have to be evacuated from
someplace and have to go to a Shel shter
that they are allowed to bring their
companion animal with them and clearly a
kangaroo would be in an inappropriate to
bring to some sort of shelter whereas I
believe like a raccoon or a squirrel can
be contained in a carrier that you can
bring with you if you needed to go to a
shelter so I kind of wanted to put that
out there too I believe that the way we
structured that uh animal shelter in
emergency they don't they can't they
don't have to be admitted in say say the
hotel is made into the shelter they
don't need to be admitted into the hotel
there needs there can it can be that the
uh accommodation for the animals can be
a an
onsite uh like um trailer or something
in the parking lot yeah yeah right okay
representative Scully thank you madam
chair do you know is there an
established vaccine schedule for these
animals in New Hampshire there's not in
New Hampshire because we don't allow
them okay so I mean I I follow
up you want to say something else I was
just going to say I I believe to the
best of my knowledge that the states
that do allow them to be kept as pets do
have vaccine schedules and and they take
them for regular vet checkups all right
that was kind of because the language of
that you have here is as so as long as
the animal is up to date on any vaccines
required but in New Hampshire you're
saying currently there are no vaccines
required currently there's not because
we don't have any allowed to be kept as
as pets thank you okay thank you any
other questions represent essentially a
followup on that that question so it
probably would make sense to have in
this bill that there should be rules
made about vaccine schedules for these
animals so that that will impact that's
a very good point that's a very good
point and it should be done through
rules because it will be an off-label
use of a vaccine um as as done in other
states thank you okay thank
you any other questions for
representative uh Spain yeah I I do have
one other question M um regarding the
language saying that the animal cannot
be confiscated do you have any
objections if that was written to State
um unless the animal bites somebody no
objection at all okay thank you I would
still love to see them have to give
permission before it's euthanized but I
think that under a bite situation that
permission should be very strongly uh
okay all right no other questions thank
you representative Spain for bringing
this bill to committee thank you all for
your time I'm going to call Kurt
good afternoon good afternoon I'm Kurt
aronburg I'm the New Hampshire state
director for the Humane Society of the
United States thank you for allowing me
to testify Madam chairman uh and the
committee
uh this bill threatens public health and
safety and promotes the dangerous and
inhumane trend of keeping wild animals
as pets raccoons and squirrels are wild
animals not domesticated pets leading
health and professional Animal Care
organizations including the American
Veterinary Medical
Association the American Public Health
Association and the national animal care
and control
Association strongly advocate for laws
that prohibit the private ownership of
wild animals much like the CDC which
advises against keeping raccoons and
squirrels as pets these groups recognize
the inherent risks that come with the
private possession of wild
animals their wild behaviors are
unpredictable and since they are
potential disease vectors it makes it
dangerous for humans to attempt to live
with them as they have the potential to
cause physical harm as well as spread
serious zoonotic disease such as rabies
according to the New Hampshire Fish and
Game department raccoons are a major
carrier of rabies a deadly disease that
can be transmitted to humans and other
animals this legislation appears to be
grounded in a mistaken belief that rabes
vaccinations are approved for the use in
wildlife and can effectively protect
Public
Health however rabies vaccines are not
licensed for use in wild animals like
raccoons and
squirrels and their safety and
Effectiveness in this species have not
been
proven in
addition to rabies raccoons can spread
other viral diseases and bacterial
fungal parasitic infections to humans
including raccoon roundworm an
intestinal parasite that affects human
and dogs and most frequently impacts
children even the smallest and youngest
animals can carry and can cause severe
injuries wild rodents such as squirrels
can carry a variety of dangerous
diseases that may not make the animal
appear sick but can still cause serious
health issues in people especially those
with chronic illnesses weakened immune
systems or who are
pregnant this bill also presents
significant Animal Welfare concerns in
just one example it would encourage the
improper handling of orphaned or injured
Wildlife instead of seeking help from
licensed Wildlife
rehabilitators individuals may try to
care for these animals on their
own when wild animals are raised in
captivity they do not learn the critical
survival skills they need to survive on
their own making them poor candidates
for safe release back into the wild
keeping wild animals as pets is also
cruel to the animals
themselves they have complex physical
and social needs that cannot be met in
captivity they are often confined to
small Barren cages which prevent them
from exhibiting natural behaviors and
suffer from poor nutrition inade quate
veterinary care and mental distress when
they become too difficult to handle or
care for as they frequently
do owners often abandon them turning
them loose where they may die or
threaten the native
ecosystem so I urge this committee to
recommend this bill in inexpedient to
legislate opening New Hampshire to the
private possession of wild animals is a
flawed and dangerous path that threatens
public health and safety and would be
harmful to the welfare of all animals
involved thank you for listening to me
today representative King thank you
madam chair um do you have any
evidence um of these other states that
have legalized you know pet ownership of
these animals have you seen evidence of
a spike in zoonotic diseases amongst the
the the pets or or attacks on humans or
all the problems that you you uh just
mentioned do do you see that happening
in the states where they've legalized I
don't I don't have any data on that okay
thank you so much represent Scully thank
you madam chair and thank you for coming
to testify um so the bill the language
of the bill says that these pets could
be adopted if they it's been determined
that they cannot live in the wild so I
know this may be a difficult question to
ask but do you think it it' be better to
euthanize them than to give them chance
at life with somebody if they can't live
on their own I mean that would be on a
Case by casee B basis by uh experts at
the scene or you know who are handling
that
case thank you represent Bix yeah um
just sort of following up on that um
the uh I think the first sentence of the
bill says raccoons and gray squirrels
may be possessed as companion animals
without a permit from the Department if
a Wildlife Rehabilitation facility makes
the determination that the animal cannot
survive in the wild and that that such
animals up to date on any vaccines
required
so uh would a wild a licensed
Wildlife um Rehabilitation facility
uh be an appropriate authority to
determine that that the animal cannot
survive in the wild and would therefore
be
eligible personally I don't think I'm
qualified to answer that but there may
be someone in the room who is uh fishing
game is here I don't know I don't have
the answer to that okay thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you
I'm asking Don Bergeron from New
Hampshire fishing game to come and speak
good
afternoon good afternoon I'm Dan burgon
I'm chief of the wildlife division with
New Hampshire Fish and Game department
I'm here um I'm here uh representing the
commission and the department in
opposition of this bill um so we have we
have a number of concerns uh with this
bill um to start I I think we we don't
believe that wild animals should be
allowed to be kept as pets um um
currently um we license Wildlife
rehabilitators uh they give Wildlife a
second chance um if we find injured
Wildlife um those individuals can care
for those animals and release them um
however our current rules actually
specify um that that if the wildlife
rehabilitator or the Consulting
veterinarian determin that the animal
can't be released back into the wild
that that the animal must be euthanized
right now now um we do believe that is
the best thing um to let nature take its
course in in the instance where the wild
where the animal cannot be released back
into the wild um we also have concerns
about some of the public health um um
issues that this brings up um so the
bill references that that a squirrel or
a raccoon would have to have any
required vaccinations currently there
are no statutes that we have that
requires vaccinations for either of
these animals um and one of the main
reasons for that is because there are no
approved vaccines for these animals
because they are wild animals um any
vaccination given to them would be
considered off Lael use um and
and the the effectiveness is not proven
and I think there would be I think you
would o open up a a lot of liability um
hanging your hanging your hat on
vaccinations for an animal that are not
approved for that for that animal um
there as was mentioned before there are
other diseases that that these animals
can carry raccoon roundworm was one K9
distemper is another one that raccoons
can get um these are things that can be
passed to pet dogs as well and again
there are no approved vaccines for these
animals and there are no current
statutes that require them and I don't
see anything in this bill that would
require these vaccinations either they
reference required vaccines but there's
nowhere in any law that that that
requires anything
um the other the other concern is that
it it I know there was some talk about
possible amendments but in its current
form um if someone were to be bitten
this not only prevents the agency from
being able to confiscate it um but also
EU euthanize it and there was some there
was some um conversation about a
quarantine but I don't see anything in
here that would allow the department to
do that under the current language um
because it very very plainly says
um um the raccoon or graay squirrel
shall not be confiscated or euthanized
without the permission of the owner and
while I would hope that most people
would be willing to do that I I would
not want to hang my hat on that for
something that's for for disease as
deadly as rabies um rabies is 100% fatal
when someone develops the symptoms um so
that's not something that that we've
ever been willing to take chances on um
so I I feel like this would tie our
hands um from being able to act
appropriately um in the event that
someone was bitten and again um even
with the vaccination those those are not
um approved for these animals um um and
there and there are no legal
requirements um so we have a lot of
concerns about this um again um the way
that our rehabilit Rehabilitation system
works um we license individuals there's
certain requirements that they have to
go through they have to work under uh
the consultation of a veterinarian
um even Wildlife rehabilitators are not
allowed to keep these animals if they
cannot release them into the wild um
those animals must be euthanized the
only instance where you can keep one of
these is under an exhibitor's permit um
so think like Squam Lake Science Center
um where you have where you have some of
these animals for educational purposes
um but even a rehabilitator would not be
allowed to keep one of these animals
unless they got an exhibitor's permit um
and then um and then had some sort of
educational program that they use the
animal for um so um So currently there's
and and I did reach out to my
counterparts in surrounding states um
when I saw this bill come out so I
reached out to Maine Massachusetts and
Vermont um I'm not I'm not sure what the
ma the map was that was presented um
they all indicated to me that none of
these animals can be owned as pets some
do have an exhibitor's permit similar to
New Hampshire does um but again those
are under very um specific circumstances
to individuals typically that have some
sort of educational purpose like Squam
Lake Science Center not not for someone
to own as a as a pet um so those are
some of the concerns that we have and
I'm happy to take any questions
representative King thank you madam
chair thank you for testifying today um
not a rhetorical question honest
question how do you define what is a
wild animal is that clearly defined in
statute is that somewhere in code or we
looking at a diction Ary definition
because when I think of like snakes and
rats and birds I think of those as wild
animals and yet people are legally
allowed to own those so how do you
define what is and is not a wild animal
and why do seemingly some wild animals
have a green green card and others not
um so there is a definition of wildlife
in our rules um when I when I reference
Wildlife I'm I'm referencing native
actual wild animals um so there's
there's likely areas of the country
where um there's um you know there's
raccoons that have been domesticated and
bred um you know that it gets a little
bit um it gets a little bit tricky still
but but you know those are maybe not a
wild animal um um so when when I'm when
we're talk I mean this build seems to
reference animals taken from the wild in
in New Hampshire so that's kind of where
where we make that distinction these
animals are coming from the wild they
weren't um they weren't bred over
generations and domesticated okay follow
up follow up so um so like snakes are
those generally bred in captivity on and
on or or I know rats are rats I think
are often always bred in captivity
you're not just grabbing Rats from the
wild but what about snakes and and as
well yeah it depends on the species
really and there are there are wild
species of rat so Norway rat we have
that New Hampshire those that's a wild
species of rat we have um numerous
native Snake species in the state of New
Hampshire um so there are various
species like that that are bred in
captivity um but but we have numerous
Wild Ones as well e Even Rats okay thank
you okay representative Bixby yeah so uh
just to to get a little bit more
clarification on how uh so the the bill
suggests that somehow if a if an animal
has been rehabilitated a wild animal has
been rehab
debilitated uh and but can't be released
into the wild that somehow that would
qualify it uh as you for being um viable
as being a pet but uh in terms of the
animal
behavior uh would that with the its wild
essentially having been wild from you
know birth to the time it was injured
would that
essentially uh make its
Behavior Uh unsuitable for household
had it it certainly could so
typically I guess I'll I'll I'll put it
this way so typically when a when a when
a wild animal is not not able to be
released back into the wild it's it's
usually because it has some sort of
severe injury um and in many cases those
injuries um may be life-threatening um
but in in a lot of others um it would
not be a good candidate for a pet
because they would likely require
substantial Specialized Care right um
otherwise if the animal was able to be
rehabilitated back to back to its full
function and released into the wild
that's that's what rehabilitators are
supposed to and required in our rules to
do um so I would have concerns that you
might end up with with animals that have
um that are in need of Specialized Care
that those would most likely be the ones
that because they're not candidates for
release back into the wild that they
would have some some pretty substantial
issues um again whether the other issue
the other issue I see is um there's
there's nothing that specifies what sort
of documentation a person would need it
just says that a rehabilitation facility
determines that it's not um not fit for
release um but there's you know from
from our Department's perspective um if
there's all sorts of people with
squirrels we still need to know somehow
um even though there's not a perit
required we still need to know that that
person um got the okay from a rehabber I
suppose but but there's no there's no
forms there's you know is it is it
simply they said yeah this this is good
to go or did they have to sign some sort
of paperwork so that's not clear how
that would how that would function and
how our department would deal with that
either followup so um so one so there's
I I see a couple of directions this bill
could go one is that um we could uh do a
lot of work on it and put together a
permit structure for someone to accept
uh a rehabilitated animal from the wild
and uh have that as a legally um
permitted Companion Animal and put
together some sort of schedule of how
vaccines for various things should
happen in rules uh or we could say that
if an animal that was found injured in
the wild is not able to be re
rehabilitated back to a level of where
Health where it can go into the wild it
would have died anyway and it's just a
dead animal uh which approach do you
think would be more
advisable I think I think the ladder is
more advisable um again we license
rehabilitators to give some of these
injured animals a second chance um but
but again um I I think I think you run
into Dangerous Ground when you start
allowing people to keep wild animals as
pets and and I guess another concern is
kind of where does it end right so we're
doing squirrels and raccoons today um we
um we run into issues with people who've
illegally taken in fawns um and um we'll
find those animals that have been kind
of kicked out um as they get older and
and or everyone loves to post things on
Facebook so we'll find out that way um I
I will
say um we we do try so so as an example
um a few years ago there was an instance
where there was a deer that someone had
clearly kept as a pet um that deer was
showing up in people's backyards and
taking handouts and and um it was so
tame that someone actually walked it
into a dog kennel um we we worked our
hardest to find a place to put that deer
so that we didn't have to euthanize it
now you can't always find a place for an
animal but we do work with um with other
other exhibitors so for example that
deer is now at Squam Lake Science Center
so um there's there's not there's not
it's not that there's never another
Avenue um but these these also happen
very infrequently and and you know the
other thing I'll point out about the
case in New York is that individual had
both of those animals illegally um that
was not an instance where he got he got
animals that were unfit for release he
he just had those animals illegally um
had those been brought to a
rehabilitator they likely would have
been been able to be released back into
the
wild thank you so um I have a question
representative Scully please take your
seat um I have a question regarding
um people who have these animals as pets
who don't live in New Hampshire and
perhaps are looking to move to New
Hampshire should they be able to bring
their pets with
them um
if I would say no if they're if if they
if they fall under these categories I
would say
no so if they've
successfully had these animals that
they've had as pets and they are
essentially domesticated and used to
being around
people they should not be able to bring
those animals with them when they move
here again we still have concerns about
the human health and safety uh issues
with this because there are no approved
vaccines for these
animals okay
um so in also you can can you I'll ask
the same question I asked of
Representative Spain um how much does it
normally cost for the state fish and
game department to rehabilitate um a
squirrel or a raccoon I mean depending
on whatever injury or whatever the
circumstances I I get that but just sort
of um
you know sort of ballpark how long would
it take many weeks of intensive care or
whatever so the cost for re the the
department does not spend any money on
Rehabilitation we license uh
rehabilitators and they um they
typically work they'll they'll have
grants and donations and things like
that um again the the length of time it
takes to rehabilitate a specific animal
is going to vary depending on the the
injuries that it has um obviously the
the you know the more the injury the
longer it's going to take but um the
department does not spend any money on
Rehabilitation other than occasionally
going out to relay an animal to a
rehabilitator um typically smaller
animals like squirrels um often times
are brought to rehabilitators by the
public themselves um it's usually larger
animals that that the department staff
will relay so things like um moose cabs
deer fawns spare Cubs those things will
transport to a rehabilitator um there's
often um is you know specialized
training that's required to be able to
handle those animals but the public by
and large takes smaller animals um to to
rehabilitator so the cost to the
department is is virtually nothing okay
and so um my last question
is so say fishing game where somebody
turns into fishing game um a a squirrel
that has been hit by a car has damaged
to its leg okay and um they're able
to bring them to you or whoever is
rehabilitating this animal
and they
can somewhat repair the damage but the
squirrel is not really
um uh you know fully functional with
that
leg so the end to that would be just
that you wouldn't want to re release it
it's healthy it's fine
but you wouldn't want to release it back
into the wild because it would be
immediate prey for somebody else um
some um Predator so that animal would
then be
euthanized um it would end up being the
determination of the rehabber and the
Consulting vet that they work with um
whether or not it should be euthanized
but if if they felt it couldn't be
released back into the wild that that
would be the determination that they
would end up making if they didn't think
it could survive in the wild okay thank
you any other questions representative H
Haskins thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question presumably
the
um professionals at the rehab places
will make that determination before they
go ahead and invest a lot of time and
energy in an animal that's likely to not
be able to be released and therefore
needs to be euthanized is that not the
case yeah that would be the case and um
so for example deer fawns with broken
legs are almost immediately euthanized
because um it's understood that that
animal likely is not going to be able to
be um now it's not always the case it
depends on the type of break and and the
ability of the vet to do something but
but that is true uh rehabilitators are
very good at assessing um injuries and
and and the potential for rehabilitation
so often times those decisions are made
relatively early on they're they're not
going to sink a lot of their because um
I so um we we work closely there's not a
lot of rehabilitators in the state um
there are a handful that do the bulk of
the work and we work very closely with
them um very dedicated people um they do
not make these decisions lightly um but
but they do really good work and and
um I've spoken to some of them and I I I
believe that they feel similar as as the
department does on this at least the
ones that I've spoken to thank
you okay and no other questions uh thank
you I appreciate your time thank you
very much and I'd like to call
nder thank you madam chair good
afternoon committee members um I asked
to co-sponsor this bill because I saw
the story about what happened in New
York and in 2011 I was the sponsor of a
bill to legalize ownership of Quaker
parrots so I don't need to tell you the
story because you could go to the gift
shop and buy a book about that um Kevin
avard who's a senator now was a freshman
legislator with me and he wrote the
story about legalizing the Quaker
parrots now at the time you were there
Kevin Kevin skull you may have even been
a
co-sponsor um Fish and Game testified
against that bill but I think they were
secretly on my side because they love
animals now listening uh to the
testimony today so many things came to
mind um a movie a book I read called the
zookeeper's wife and she had all kinds
of of interesting pets an armadillo a
badger maybe a squirrel I'm not really
sure uh the snow the squirrel apocalypse
I do remember that because it was a
bumpy ride anywhere we went that year
and I thought it I thought it was an
omen and it turns out maybe it was
because Co
followed um's see I I you had mentioned
rehabilitating animals I actually had a
friend who who did that she was a a
stunt woman in movies and one of the
little animals that the police brought
her to take care of was a baby skunk
baby skunk was in the car with her doing
a stunt in a movie and was able to be in
the credits so the baby skunk was in the
credits she would uh bring she brought a
baby squirrel to to gym class we do a
weightlifting class together and I I
remember that little animal and I didn't
I'm like wow you can you have a pet
squirrel the police brought it to her
because they knew that she cared for
animals and that little squirrel
couldn't even open its eyes um but it
turned its head because we were all
fussing over it like it was a baby it
turned its head towards her even though
I couldn't see I'm like oh my gosh he
thinks you're it's you're his mother or
she um so oh and the ferrets you also
mentioned the ferrets at the time when
we were discussing legalizing quaker
parrots did hear from others about the
ferrets and how they were taken and
euthanized before they were legalized
and they had all kinds of concerns
concerns about those as well um I never
thought about the rabies but um I think
that was everything I had on my notes um
I do support the bill representative
King thank you madam chair thank you for
testifying to State um in light of the
concerns uh the Department of ficient
Game had um do you feel like this bill
could use some amendments to clarify
some things or fix some things or do you
still like it as is um I I do what you
have to do I love animals I know I know
the Department of Fish and Game also
does care for them so yeah I'm fine with
amendments any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you
representative ner thank you uh my last
Snider oh you have one for this bill
could you please pass it to
me
yeah please state your name and uh where
you're from for the record good
afternoon good afternoon my name is
Christina Snider I live in Chester New
Hampshire and I'm an animal rights
activist and I love raccoons and
squirrels so I'm here for on their
behalf today and I'll just uh I'm just
going to read a couple of things that
I've researched and uh this is uh some
comments from a woman from another state
who does own raccoons and she works with
wildlife rehabbers and she runs a
raccoon I mean yes a raccoon page on
Facebook and she says please before you
decide to get a raccoon for a pet talk
to some of us that have them in our
lives it is a lifechanging event in
every
aspect the they are a 15 to 20 year
commitment raccoons are only for those
that live their lives around these
raccoons they cannot be caged they will
go nuts they destroy everything in their
path they bite you for no reason at
times they are wild animals they love
you one minute try to bite the next it's
just part of being a raccoon everything
is on their terms not yours and then
there's also a company Critter Control
which is a nuisance company a Humane
nuisance company so they're going to
know about raccoons because they deal
with them all the time and they actually
have a page saying why raccoons should
not be pets and this is a couple of
their points is uh behavior and
temperament raccoons are smart curious
active and playful animals however they
are also demanding attention seeking and
unpredictable Born To Rome wild raccoons
can act out when held captive when then
we will have a raccoon that cannot be
wild and take care of themselves loose
outside they are known to act out if
they are unhappy once a raccoon reaches
sexual maturity the cute and cuddly baby
becomes unpredictable when upset or
Moody raccoons can act like hormonal
teenagers these selfish Critters can
turn vengeful aggressive and territorial
in an instant all to assert their
dominance their their tendency to act
out makes interacting with others close
to Impossible in a human home raccoons
often feel trapped which can stir up
extra agitation and hatred to fuel the
fire they damage to the house they are
rors their natural range for a raccoon
is 1 to three miles locking them inside
of a house goes against their nature
they need large open spaces and then to
talk about squirrels this is someone who
uh used to own squirrels razor sharp
claws razor sharp teeth High
Intelligence High curiosity and the
ability to get anywhere they feel like
makes them iffy pets especially if you
value your home furnishings and or your
intact skin they aren't mean but they
don't understand how they can Flay you
when leaping off or playing and then
there is a veterinarian uh page and they
are address uh squirrels in particular
so these are veterinarian saying these
words the squirrel owns you if you want
to go away you will need to find a house
sitter with lots of and a high pain
tolerance sharp squirrel Nails those
Nails which are designed to pierce bark
and allow them to climb trees completely
rake skin sharp squirrel teeth they do
not possess the bite inhibition reflex
of domestic pets if the first thing that
crosses their brain is to bite there is
no counter message to say this is a bad
plan and given all of these things so
now if people own these racons where
they have them as pets and they take on
something that that is a little over the
top and they didn't realize what they
were doing my fear is that they can't
handle these animals they will put that
animal in their car they will drive
somewhere in the middle of nowhere and
they will dump them people dump wild
animals all the time to relocate them
off their property that is against the
law and then also this is this could
possibly even happen if that CH if that
raccoon or squirrel scratches their
child and they get really mad they could
just take that raccoon or squirrel
outside and shoot them who's to know and
then uh I don't think that this animal
is in the this bill is in the animal's
best interest and I want to say too is
that we already have domestic animals we
have dogs and cats and currently right
now there are hundreds of them
languishing in shelters across the state
of New Hampshire and now we want to add
more pets to the mix and I will say when
we're talking about rabies with cats
they're not registered like dogs some
people own cats and never get their
shots they never have rabies shots so I
have a of a big uh worry about who's
going to police these raccoons and these
squirrels to make sure that they get
their shots so uh just in closing I I I
hope that you oppose this bill I think
there's way too many concerns and it is
for the best interest of the animals
thank
you okay um so I have a
question um you cited some testimony
from people outside of New Hampshire who
own
raccoons um
how do you think that they would feel if
their state banned them from having
those pets I mean obviously they keep
them as pets they like them as
pets yeah I'm sure that they love their
raccoons because uh but they're just
kind of warning the public about this is
what you're going to get into and what I
would hope would happen and I you know I
don't have any expert or legal expertise
but I would hope that there would be
loopholes in grandfather in once because
that's in my experience that's usually
what happens when a new gets past um
there's grandfathered clause for people
that already own those animals and then
that would prevent them from owning them
again once those animals
pass any other questions representative
uh King thank you madam chair I'm sorry
maybe you uh mentioned it and I missed
it but did you make a distinction really
between squirrels and raccoons because I
remember you talking a lot about
raccoons and it's not Humane to own them
and stuff but squirrels they seem like a
different you know I mean they a
different Beast altogether but they seem
like they're quite domesticable what are
your thoughts on that yeah I I did maybe
because I'm a little nervous but maybe
the first half was about uh raccoon and
then it delved into squirrels and the
squirrels are the ones where o sorry it
says razor sharp claws razor sharp teeth
High Intelligence High curiosity and
abil ability to get anywhere and it says
they have sharp squirrel Nails sharp
teeth there is uh just as an example
there are several groups of these states
that do own squirrels and there there's
some social media groups and even these
people who have owned squirrels in these
states they point up their finger and
say oh the squirrel got me today as the
finger is dripping with blood they have
sharp teeth they can chew through
Hickory nuts so that's dangerous and I
worry about children and and other
pets
so okay I was follow up I will just
really more thinking about the the
humanity of a squirrel being you know
cuz it sounds like raccoons really don't
want to be domesticated they need 3
miles like you said a r radius of range
but it seems like squirrels yeah they
bite but so do other animals um but are
they Miserable as as pets and it seems
to me at least through my very limited
knowledge that squirrels actually are
fairly happy as as pets did you did you
mention that or your thoughts on that I
think it it depends you know there was
actually and this might cause you to
laugh but there was actually scientific
proof that that's squirrels have
distinct personality so I think it
depends on the squirrel there's actually
more here where it says from what I've
heard some squirrels take to
domestication and will hang out with you
all their life While others hit puberty
and want nothing more to do with you
than to go to the wild if you get a pup
and invest perhaps they will but there's
no
guarantees thank you any other questions
from the
committee represent Scully hi thank you
and thank you for taking my question I
don't know if you know the answer to
this or not but can squirrels be like
house broken like cats and trained to
use litter box or I I do not think
squirrels do from what I've seen on
these social media groups they usually
have a habitat setup in their home or
maybe outside kind of similar to ever
seen those out outdoor enclosures for
cats and they'll you know they keep them
in there and then newspaper and things
like that and as far as raccoons they
may be trained to use a litter box but I
do not know for sure all right thank you
okay any other questions thank you for
O'Brien it's our last pink card if
anybody else wishes to speak on
this okay thank you good afternoon
welcome to environment and agriculture
thank you very much Joan O'Brien from
Amhurst and uh I opposeed the bill I
think we all felt really terrible when
peanut you know the squir and Fred the
raccoon got confiscated and killed and
it was actually as an animal Advocate I
was heartened to see how many people in
this country were really outraged by
that because it shows how much we care
about animals so that was wonderful um I
believe you know wild animals belong in
the wild that's been said we don't want
to do anything that would encourage more
people from taking wild animals and
bringing them into their
homes
um representative King was asking about
the difference between between wild and
domestic lots of things have made that
crossover if they enter the pet trade
there's a lot of um room for Animal
Welfare issues because you get that
profit motive involved and then you've
got people selling snakes selling
ferrets and people that aren't doing a
very good job of taking care of the
animals so in general we just we want
more wild animals wild and fewer
domesticated so with peanut and Fred it
seems to me that the his Guardian had I
read he had tried to release the
squirrel and the squirrel came back to
his house and i' had read he was in the
process of of trying to obtain a permit
when they were
confiscated so I don't know how things
work in New York but I mean we do have a
process that Dan berson explained about
getting a permit so that you can be an
exhibitor of the squirrel and these
peanut and Fred seem to be sort of you
know educational animals so that would
have made sense to be an exhibitor they
were on
YouTube um it's some hoops you have to
jump through but I think that's
appropriate if you're motivated you
probably could have kept those animals
with a permit to be an exhibitor if he
had done the right things this guy in
New York there's somebody in um New
Hampshire's got a skunk just one skunk
he's an exhibitor maybe it was the same
situation a skunk that he rescued and
couldn't
release um I know down in Massachusetts
there was a rehab or she had a I think
it was a porcupine that she didn't think
could be released so he's living there
forever um but there was she was
challenged you know that she was asked
to release him but she was able to prove
that he couldn't survive on his own he's
going to live out his life with the
rehabber that's an option if people have
the space and then just lastly I'll say
um rep wheer brought up the gray
squirrels in the UK um did you know that
Japan's overrun with raccoons because of
a book called Rascal it came out in the
60s and then it became a movie and then
it became a series a cartoon series in
Japan and even though the whole theme of
the series was what a rascal he was and
how he wasn't a good pet it it sparked a
whole like craze of everybody wanting a
raccoon so now Japan is overwhel with
raccoons and uh so you know morals right
that's a lesson to be learned thank you
any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you so much
for your test ony um and I don't have
any more pink cards so if somebody can
grab the blue sheet up there um on the
online portal we have registered 16
people who support this bill and 72 who
oppose uh one person is
neutral
sheet thank you representative Scully
on the blue sheet we have two people
opposed and those folks have spoken and
given their testimony so I'm going to
to and I'm I apologize for being behind
in schedule we should have started this
hearing at 2 o' but here we are at 22
after 2 I'm going to open up the hearing
for
uh HB 263 although I not sure who is
gavel yeah I don't know so we'll just
hang on one minute
because somebody was supposed to be
introducing I this is a representative
so she's out she had to go out
um let's see now yeah I'm gonna I'm G to
wait for representative Bixby because I
think he was supposed to introduce the
bill for
so hang on one moment right here thank
you so much thank you we're going to
wait one minute for uh representative
it mam chair yes sir you're about out of
card oh okay representative Scully would
you go I'll let uh Jamie know that we
need some more pink
right here you just pass them up
here you can come on up oh I'll grab
it thank
yeah so apparently I'm introducing this
bill apparently that's Barbara had
mentioned that to me earlier so that's
why I had thought just hold on one
second let representative wheeler take
his seat um and I believe uh
representative H Haskin stepped out
momentarily too so let me give a a
minute or two and then we'll get
underway anybody have pink cards for HP
here okay you fill out card for me I
will
okay all right representative H Haskins
underway all right going to open up the
hearing for HB
263 relative to applications to the cost
of care fund for livestock care and uh
represent resentative Bixby you are
introducing this bill on behalf of
Representative ktoa thank you so much
yes thank you uh representative Peter
Bixby from do straford 13 um and just
want to clarify I I am introducing this
bill I am a co- sponsor but I am simply
introducing this bill I am not
testifying and when you are done
introducing the bill you may take your
seat so um this is relative to
applications to the cost of care fund
for livestock care and the bill
essentially puts further restrictions on
how uh applications will be uh assessed
okay thank you appreciate you bringing
that
forward I now call um commissioner Sean
263 thank you madam chair chman members
of the committee for the record I am
Shan Jasper commissioner of the
Department of Agriculture markets and
food I am here to testify against the
bill as
written um so you
would have to read this bill in the
context of chapter
644 which is where the seizure of
animals can take place I know that um
House Bill six 16 is coming along and
frankly I would suggest that if you feel
there's a need for um
263 then you should probably incorporate
it into the bill so that we don't end up
with uh a conflict because if the loss
stays as it is there would be a a fairly
dramatic uh conflict and that is under
current law in chapter
644 there is no requirement that there
be a
consultation with anyone who has
experience in the care of um the type of
animals that is being seized so what
would happen is the law enforcement
agency would lawfully seize the animals
under the current law and then apply to
me for care and I would have to deny
that if they weren't aware that prior to
applying and prior to to seizing the
animals they needed to bring somebody in
uh I think that's very
confusing uh and really isn't the way we
should should be moving forward the
other problem and the bigger problem for
me is there is no way a Commissioner of
Agriculture should be put in the
position of deciding whether a law
enforcement agency acted
lawfully that's just way beyond my
capability that's what the courts of for
I have consulted with the Attorney
General's office on this and they agree
with me that I should not be put in this
this position uh and that this is a
matter for the courts so in in essence
um I would ask you to to kill the bill
and if you see any need for this type of
of thing to be done just do it when you
do uh
616 and I'd be glad to answer any
questions
okay yeah no um I remember when um we
were drafting up hb6 2016 and I don't
like to really refer to other bills
especially haven't they haven't been
heard yet in our committee um but when
we were putting together that
legislation I know that there was a
piece uh having to do with the cost of
care fund and it was suggested that we
tease that out and do it
separately uh as we did with with the F
and Colt Bill and
um I guess there was the law enforcement
training piece also there was a number
of different things and we didn't want
to kind of jam everything on into one
piece of legislation so that's kind of
how this came about that um this this
bill was a separate entity um
so I I can I can actually appreciate you
know wanting to at least keep this piece
in with the other bill um and and make
it sort of like a kind of clarifies why
we want to make whatever change to that
um Co to the cost of care fund so would
you
agree um though
that certain language then maybe not
this particular language but other
language having to do with the
application of cost of care fund um then
be addressed in in some other way I I
would and my my recollection of the
those discussions were that what we were
talking about in the cost of care fund
were totally different than what I'm
seeing here and that what we had talked
about didn't create a conflict uh and
didn't put the commissioner of
agriculture in a position of of making
decisions on what was legal or not so so
I I certainly appreciate that and have
often advised that but when they are
intricately tied together and cannot
operate separately than they need to be
in my opinion in one bill I ultimately
don't think that any of the things in
this bill are necessary if the
underlying problems particularly are are
uh addressed I have had no no situations
where I've had any questions about
applications where
um the law wasn't
followed nor have uh any any any issues
Arisen where there appeared not to have
been good reason for um seizing the
animals I think all of this has got to
do with the Lee case which in my opinion
which I couldn't apply my opinion to the
legal standard the animals were not
seized they were
appeared to be using the section of the
law that allowed for protective custody
which does not in my opinion apply when
um the owners were present and that
allowed the animals not to be seized but
to be taken into protective custody that
created a real mess and I and I
certainly hope that that is addressed in
616 and whatever form to take care of
some of the problems that exist um so I
mean I don't think that the second part
of the bill we're we're talking about uh
does any real harm except again the
language has to be consistent because on
the one hand 616 and I know you don't
want to talk about it talks about the
state
veterinarian this talks about someone
with specific knowledge and the care of
those animals that is not necessarily
going to be the state veterinarian
because like any practitioner they have
limited knowledge they are not
necessarily going to be experts in the
care of ferrets or any number of of
areas you know the state veterinarian is
particularly knowledgeable about bovine
but not others so we have to be careful
about having two sets of Standards
because somebody could think well we
consulted with the state veterinarian
sees the animals and then I could say
well the state veterinarian doesn't
actually know anything about
Frets and so then what do we do so
representative Bixby thank you sir so uh
thank you for taking my question um the
uh it seems that um I I'm I I I
co-sponsored this not having read it in
a whole lot of detail um and with the
general idea that it was um to do
something about the Lee case um but uh
looking at it more carefully it seems
like what this is trying to do is have
you make a determination about whether
something was properly seized and if
that was not the case then uh deny
funding for it and uh is
uh is it something is that an
appropriate um thing for you be to be
doing when you assessing applications
for funding under the cost of care fund
I do not believe so because the animals
that would be seized and let me be
clear none of the animals in the in the
Lee case there has been no application
to the fund and I would deny that if
there were because the animals were not
seized because no arrest was made which
was required under law in order for they
um them to be eligible so the Lee case
has nothing to do with it I make
determination certainly on
fines um based on the
law when it comes to any number of
things
pesticides you name it I do make those
determinations to issue fines but never
am I put in this situation to judge
whether the state police County Town
acted
lawfully and in all the other cases is
there is a internal adjudication system
where those appeals can be made this
would be something that could only I
think be appeal to the to the courts and
so if a police department sees this I
said I'm not paying now we've got you
know the town of Hudson suing the
Commissioner of Agriculture because I
determined that they acted unlawfully I
I can't be put in that situation that is
just to me that is ridiculous
okay so uh my question to you is
regarding the cost of care fund and and
you making decisions about when funds
should be released or applied to cost of
care um what are the parameters are that
that you consider yeah certainly first
of all we need you know to know what the
case was so it's you know town of XYZ
versus
you know Sally Jones and we can see if
in fact there's a case we're usually
aware of them anyhow and then there is a
perdum uh for the care of of types of
animals and then there are Veterinary
spes and the state veterinarian goes
through those and determines whether or
not um the particular type of care was
an emergency or not because we only pay
for emergency veterinary care not oh
well it needs its toenails clipped or it
needs a rabies vaccination we think it
may not be you know up to speed and
sometimes it needs grooming and that
would be in a case where the conditions
were horrific and the thing is covered
with lice or you know fleas or or
something but if it was just oh we
wanted to give it a bath we we wouldn't
pay for that so there is a process we go
and look look at what are the conditions
what are the
circumstances um that led to the medical
care does your agency have rules we do
have rules uh having to do with what are
appropriate uh dis dispensation for
funds and which are not so there are
rules but they don't you know and they
get down into the maximum cost per day
po you know for horses for dogs for cats
for Birds um do you do you have the
section of uh rules that this falls
under I do not uh that is you can go to
the web the website and find the the uh
rules there I mean I think that would be
as easy just to look on the Department's
websites look on the department of
animal industry look at the cost of care
and the rules that go go with that
application okay any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you so much
you're
welcome uh have one p one last pink card
regarding HP
263 and that is from Rob Johnson New
Bureau I'm gonna take the nice chair you
take the nice
benette thank you madam chair members of
the committee for the record Rob Johnson
representing the New Hampshire Farm
Bureau as a federation's policy
director I me as I mentioned mentioned
earlier there were three bills that we
worked on with the chair with uh
representative Bixby and representative
comtois and this is number two of the
three
and what it does is add some uh language
in the the uh cost of care fund now the
RSA now the cost of care fund was
established it two two years
ago maybe four years ago maybe fairly
recently anyway for the for the purposes
of and I believe I'm I I wrote down the
quote assisting municipalities in in
covering cost of care and cured from
caring for Animals pending the
resolution of any action brought for
animal
cruelty
and another statute you may want to be
aware of most of you probably are but I
just wanted to point out in the in the
animal cruelty statutes under
Roman uh five
four excuse me Roman 4B it's it's it
states that um the investigating officer
for
livestock as defined in and then the RSA
defining livestock she'll be accompanied
by veterinarian license under RSA 332b
that's the veterinary Practice Act or
the state veterinarian Who Shall Set the
probable cars criteria for taking the
animal or
animals and what we're again as as the
commissioner said what uh what these
this bill and the bill you've heard
about that's coming up are addressing is
is a situation in Lee which you'll hear
a lot more about and there are a couple
other situations that were similar and
would wanted to tie the fact that in
that situation uh for whatever reason
the officials uh in where livestock were
were were taken um did not consult with
with anybody with expertise in livestock
care the care of the livestock that were
seized and our thinking was that um
prior to the commissioner uh releasing
funds that there should be some type of
check off where there's an insurance
that an insurance that uh you know that
expertise was
consulted um getting to the exact
language of the bill and looking at it
and we're in agreement that the the uh
the language stating law lawfully is is
is goes above and beyond what would be
required that that does a step up where
he the commission would have to consult
with expertise in his Department that he
he doesn't he doesn't really have and
what we're really looking for is that
there just be assurances that there was
a a you know a consultation a discussion
with
expertise uh whether it be you know an
extension livestock
specialist uh a known expert in the
field a uh assurance that was a
veterinarian that had some uh you know
knowledge of the of the the livestock
bnc's we we know we we see that as part
of uh it's a due process for for the the
animal owner I have uh I've talked with
the sponsor represent ktoa and and and
she's in she's in agreement of of
striking the the lawful language um I I
as you heard the commissioner speak and
I've talked with him and and um I I I
obviously you heard that he he obviously
you know feels it's a that's a burden
and like I said we agree we also uh
aren't opposed to you rolling it into uh
uh the bill coming up um we that's kind
of where we had it but we thought it I
know why it was parsel all because it
does deal with the cost of care fund and
there was a lot there we were trying to
trying to uh I think just uh uh I know
help everybody's understanding by
talking about these issues separately so
I uh I think I've covered what I wanted
to say Madam chair and I I'll oh excuse
me there is one thing that if you were
to move forward with this in in in any
way um would also need some amending
language in 644 itself uh relative to so
that people would know UPF front that if
uh a municipality is applying for this
cost of care funding that they do need
to uh consult with uh individuals and
again part of it is just we we want it
to be upfront and so that uh
municipalities know before incurring
funding that okay we've got to do this
we we got to make sure that our you know
our our officials are trained to know
that they they need to bring in some
expertise which is what we are striving
for so thank you for your time and
attention as always and I'll leave it
that okay representative Bixby yes so um
you you mentioned that you would be
opposed to putting this into
616 I'm sorry if I said that I meant the
exact opposite oh so you would be you
would be okay if we it this and then
worked and then decided when we were
looking at 66 if there was some way to
if it was appropriate to work it into
that rolling it into correct yes okay so
you would be in favor of that're that
makes a big difference it does thank you
you're welcome okay any other questions
committee okay seeing none I'm going to
uh have the blue sheet
this um on the online portal we had
seven people register their support for
this bill one person registered
opposition
nobody
okay
y I am going to close out the
okay anybody else have pink sheets for
hear
okay just resetting myself
here
um okay we have a fair number of pink
sheets uh uh Pink cards so I I will just
start before I open the the hearing I am
going to uh limit our
um our testimony to 3 minutes uh after
the um Prime sponsor presents her
bill uh and I just want to get myself
set for that and my my clerk is all set
okay so I am going to open up the
hearing for HB
152 prohibiting the sale and use of
adhesive based rodent traps and I'm
welcoming representative Linda Haskin
our very own Linda H
Haskins um to present this bill to our
committee thank you thank you madam
chair and thanks for the opportunity to
introduce this
bill so for the record my name is Linda
H Haskins I represent Rockingham 11
exor to understand this issue I will
identify the why the how and The Who
of controlling unwanted
rodents the why is an obvious
one rodents are
pests uh these traps these um adhesive
to
catch
rodents also catch animals and Wildlife
for which we have plenty of
evidence they ins snare non-target
innocent Wildlife including song birds
squirrels of both colors I would imagine
kittens and the
like they represent in my view a 19th
century
solution when 2 first century
mitigations are
available last session we we heard
testimony on this issue that there are
no viable alternatives to these
traps those who support this bill
inaccurate in the not too distant
past first generation rodenticides were
thought to be the only viable response
to Pest
Removal until their toxicity led to the
development of second generation
rodenticides today we have evidence that
rodents and other animals caught in glue
traps face a slow painful and extremely
drawn out death until they die of
starvation in a panic to escape they
often rip off patches of skin fur and
even chew off body parts in a vain
attempt to free
themselves now we learn that there are
additional more Humane treatments
available for rodent
control as to the how addressing Pest
Control begins with
exclusion or habitat
mitigation this is common
sense after that the options for Pest
Control include clude infrared solar
powered pest repellent ultrasonic
cordless devices that emit high pitched
alarms in audible to humans but not to
animals copper filled wire mesh scent
barriers bait boxes essential oils with
powerful fast acting Botanical
ingredients Earth kind repellent pouches
and most recently and interestingly an
able form of fertility
control pest
contraception that is being used across
the country in cities to good
effect please note that we Exempted the
use of insect repellents in this
ban lastly as to the who multiple
organizations have outlawed these glut
traps virtually all animal rights
organizations including the New
Hampshire animal rights League the
people for the ethical treatment of
animals and
aabon organizations include the New
Hampshire fishing game the CDC the
Humane Society businesses such as Target
Dollar General Dollar Tree R Aid
Walgreens and 100 at least US airports
exclude glue
traps countries include England SC
Scotland Ireland Iceland and New Zealand
for just a
few with knowledge comes action it's
time to act on these merciless glue
traps in favor of Humane 21st century
methods of pest
control and lastly I would just say that
I I've heard that it's a tool in the
toolbox and it reminded me that when I'm
trying to kill a mosquito before it
bites me I don't use a
sledgehammer this is an animal cruelty
Bill the reason why we we have received
over 200 emails in support of this bill
and why you see the people behind me is
evidence of the reality that animals and
Wildlife are being caught and tortured
in these
traps I'll stop here and let the folks
behind me make the case why these traps
need to be
outlawed thank you representative King
you have a question thank you madam
chair and thank you representative for
your testimony um two questions I don't
know who I don't know who's going to
come after you to speak so I don't know
if we're going to get anybody who speaks
in favor of the glue traps but um if you
can't find these in stores anymore how
are people getting them are they getting
them online and then my second question
is why if you can put yourself in the
shoes of the person who would use these
why are people feeling like they still
need these or want these or why are they
being used at all so those two questions
firstly you can find them in plenty of
places I just mentioned places that
aren't unwilling to sell them um why are
they being used they're effective
they're very sticky
the problem is that they don't exclude
the kinds of wandering Critters that you
find in a barn and other places on your
property from getting stuck on them and
they're extremely difficult to extract
those that get caught on them from them
um but why would people choose a sticky
glue trap over say uh a spring loaded
you know mouse trap or something like
that well of course I don't know why
they would because I would not MH so I
don't I don't feel that I can answer the
question all I all I could say is they
work mhm but they the cost of what they
do is not worth it when there are other
Humane Alternatives thank you
representative
Barber thank you madam chair
representative H Haskins could you give
me a clarification please does hb152
effect uh sticky traps um used for
insect control thank you for that
question no they do not there is no
mention in this bill about insects uh
this is merely a bill to Outlaw a
certain type of adhesive backed trap
that is used for rodents thank you
represent Bixby yeah I have a question
about um how the enforcement works so
does this require the Department of
Agriculture to enforce the sales um
prohibition thank you for the question
no this would come under the trade and
commerce act um they would have to do
the uh sale prohibition rather than the
Department of Agriculture thank you okay
representative Gruber yes uh thank you
uh Madam chair and thank you for
testifying the um I understand that um
people buy a lot of things online now um
and uh sometimes if you try to buy a
pesticide they say not in this state not
this state uh would that be uh possible
with this too if this pass to be able to
stop the online purchase of these well I
I didn't take that up in the bill it's
an excellent question I guess I was
concerned with New Hampshire to start
there um obviously the different states
do have different laws and I'm concerned
that we start with our own state so my
my one thought if this passes then uh
trying to uh stop
online purchases through that process
that they seem to have I'd be glad if we
reduced them at the very least right
thank
you um my question to you is
um so how do you differentiate
between a glue board that's used to trap
a mouse or rat versus a glue board that
is used to uh capture spiders or uh um
cockroaches or some
other well insect yeah in the regard to
Insects it's not the case that they're
used these are not used for insects now
are there some insects that come across
them I suppose that's possible but
they're apt to be flying we've all seen
the fly strips and many of us have used
them because the flying insects are the
ones that I don't see why you'd use use
these traps for but by the same token a
cockroach that walks across it would get
caught on it as well but it the my point
in saying that was that people need
insect
traps like fly strips that's not what
this bill is aimed at but are you aware
that there are glue boards that are used
to capture cockroaches during for
cockroach infestation and also glue
boards that are used to capture fleas
for flea infestations as well and they
are the flat glue glue boards that are
exactly the same as um these rodent
traps that you're talking about I do
believe that there are other mitigations
used for those insects as well okay
thank you any other questions for
representative H
Haskins seeing none thank you for
introducing this bill and I would uh
again I'm going to to uh limit our time
for Testimony to 3 minutes I call Sue
sasu SC sccu I'm sorry if I mispronounce
it um please come and
um and tell tell your
testimony let us know who you are and um
we are not allowed to use any kind of um
um props so do you want to see what they
you okay thank you for letting me speak
um I spend the summers at Hampton Beach
and the winters in Vermont so I
appreciate the opportunity to talk I'm a
Humane officer with 40 years experience
please speak closer to the mic thank you
and name and town name and town
Bridgewater Vermont Hampton Beach New
Hampshire I'm a home health care
provider in addition to a Humane officer
and recently we had an experience I take
care of a gentleman in his 80s and one
of the care providers brought in a glue
trap Lloyd is when Lloyd saw the mouse
in the Trap he didn't want the traps
there anyways but the poor thing was
alive held down by the whiskers held
I did manage to take the mouse to a vet
to be euthanized if the mon law it says
animals should be free from torture and
torment there's torture and torment
involved in those things I picked up
that glue trap to get rid of it and my
fingers it was hard to get that off and
I only had a little bit on we went and
we bought a live trap which can catch up
to five mice even more and then take and
relocate them fix the reason why
preaches are coming in um but it was
very distressful to the gentleman I take
care of to see something suffering like
that and
screaming and to answer the question
that I believe you asked why would
somebody use it the person the care
provider her husband um came out to me
and said where is my trap I said well
what trap are you talking about he said
my glue trap I said
I have it he said well I want it I said
why why would you use that when there's
a Humane
alternative he said I like to
kill
okay um it's not an easy death and it
doesn't have to
be any
questions any questions representative
wheeler thank you for coming today what
is your name Sue gasu Su gasu do you
want me to spell it yeah s k a s k i w
okay no other questions from the
committee thank you so much for coming
today may I leave those there for people
to look at sure
Karns hi everyone my name is Matha cnon
Hampshire I have a little
statement hello committee members thank
you for listening to me speak today my
name is Samantha Kerns I live in
Goffstown New Hampshire and I'm here to
ask you to vote in favor of
hb152 I'd like to tell you some things
about myself a brief story and some
facts I'm not an animal rights activist
I come from a line of farmers Hunters
fishermen and meat eaters I love birds
and I know the state bird of every state
I work for the Department of Health and
Human servic in the Bureau of family
assistance I work in the main district
office on Pleasant Street just a few
miles up the road from here the building
is over a hundred years old and if
you've never had a chance to explore the
tunnels and hear the history of the
building I strongly encourage it this
past August I was outside during my
lunch break enjoying the sun when a
supervisor came to me in a panic held in
her hand stuck to a glue trap with a
tiny Mouse struggling to free itself I
ran to get some dish soap water and
gloves and her and I worked together to
save this tiny Mouse from his sticky
fate my supervisor explained to me where
she had found that Mouse there had been
some noise in another office that had
been going on for a few days while
construction was going on in that
building um and she was trying to figure
out where it was when she found that
glue trap this meant that that Mouse had
been stuck to that cardboard with
Superglue for days trying to chew his
leg off bite through the cardboard and
glue twisting his body getting himself
more and more stuck until he either died
or was found after we saved him I held
his tiny body in my hands and she asked
me what it we do now and the answer
seemed obvious to me we let nature take
its course and do what nature does as we
always should have done we don't
interfere in his little life as I looked
at his tiny face with his left eye glued
shut and his right leg Twisted in an
unnatural way I realized that he was
going to die his death would be slow and
painful and it could have been prevented
if the state had used any other method
of rodent control a snap trap whether
wooden or enclosed would have ended his
life instantly and a problem that we had
created I placed him under the stairs
outside the abandoned parts of the
building if you get it's like a really
great building I really encourage you
guys to go to it it's so fun um but I
placed him under the stairs um outside
some of the abandoned parts of the
building a department that works every
day to help people who are struggling
help to torture and kill one of God's
innocent and divinely crafted creatures
because it was in the wrong place at the
wrong time no state in America has
banned glue traps yet there are some
towns this is another chance for New
Hampshire to be first in the nation this
doesn't need to be a slippery slope
fallacy stretching into in insect traps
or the BL Banning of all types of traps
and poisons it can just be rodent-based
glue traps there's also already legal
precedent for this RSA 42733 there are
already Provisions for the Humane
slaughtering of livestock and that it be
as fast and painless as possible in RSA
6448 there's discussion of animal
cruelty to animals which includes wild
animals and captivity that they should
not be made to needlessly
suffer when our fish and game officers
state troopers and most local police
officers come across wild animals
involved in a catastrophic accident they
end its life as quickly as possible to
ease its suffering fishing game also
your testimony if you can conclude sure
fishing game also works to preserve the
safety and well-being of other dangerous
and disease caring mammals such as bats
that may be unwelcomed in human spaces
um and I'll just conclude with when I
first spoke with my state reps about
this bill I know that it had died in in
committee last year but when I had first
spoke with them um you know some of them
said oh you should talk to your
supervisor and you are my supervisor
right you guys control the budgets to
how you hire the Commissioners the
Commissioners get the budgets to pick
who we use for Pest Control in the state
and so the um I always like to come with
a compromise for things right like so
you could also create a policy that we
don't use glue traps in state
facilities um I have a lot of other
testimony in here but I know you said
three minutes so I'll thank you do
anybody have any other questions any
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you so much for coming today and
do you have written testimony to
share
you call um commissioner Sean Jasper to
speak Rob the chair is too big to move
around um I am commissioner Shan Jasper
and I am in opposition to the bill um
and you know you heard well some people
say this is a tool in the
toolbox in fact it
is uh just that and I have tried
virtually every method that has been
talked about they don't work on
squirrels the biggest problem that we
have in many of our buildings my house
with four Big M three big Maples now is
squirrels generally they spring the
traps without um getting caught I did
get one one time up in the attic by the
tail and then what do you do when you
have a squirrel in the Attic caught in a
springtrap I tell you there was only one
thing I could do I put a cat up in the
attic that took care of the problem
people aren't going to like to hear that
either this is a story from that began
two Saturdays ago at the Hudson
Historical Society where I'm a member of
the board of directors and being the
person who lives closest to that
building I'm on the call list the alarms
went off went there with the police off
officer saw four French doors had the
bottoms chewed to
Pieces we saw the squirrel put in snap
traps havah Heart Traps electric
traps and I put down glue traps it took
over a week before we were able to get
that squirrel and it was the glue trap
that finally got it what are we supposed
to do when you have a situation like
that and you have a big old 1890
Victorian house and you can't get the
squirrel out of there I don't think
these should be used out of Outdoors ban
that but I think we if you don't want to
use them don't use them but I don't know
what I would do I have a self- storage
building I can't put snap traps in the
hallways you know that's little kids are
at danger the have hearts don't
generally work and I'll tell you if you
don't check it every day just like with
a glut trap that animal is going to
suffer and starve to death just as much
as if it was in a glue trap if you check
your traps on a regular basis it'll be
fine but I do have to tell you um that
aside the problem is with this bill on
page two uh section two starting on 911
this puts this under the Department of
Agriculture RSA 430 pesticides this is
not a pesticide I sit as chairman of the
pesticides board we do not deal with
this you heard the sponsor say that this
doesn't put the enforcement under it the
bill specifically does it also gives us
the power for stop orders and penalties
and the penalty for violating section
430 under the pesticides law is up to
$1,000 so while you were told that
that's not the case it absolutely is the
case and if you do nothing else you you
need to take this out of 430 thank you
any questions for the
commissioner um I do have a question um
regarding uh use in state
buildings um and I know you said that
this is not anything that comes under
Department of Agriculture purview first
of all is that is that a true statement
it doesn't come under state of we don't
regulate glute glute traps at all we
don't regulate you know any any of these
things that are not not specifically a
pesticide or a poison I think and I
haven't looked into to the other things
but no I don't believe we do certainly
state buildings you know the legislature
can make Poli do you know if if these
are being used in state buildings I
would have no way of of knowing that
okay thank you any other questions from
the
committee seeing none thank you
commissioner for coming and speaking
slepian I'm
sorry oh yes rep Scully please take your
good afternoon thank you please put your
microphone on just press the button
there you go thank you and pull it a
little towards you lights on yeah yeah
you got it thank
you pull it a little towards you the the
microphone so we can hear
you thank you so much okay you're good
okay thank you please state your name
where you're from yes my name is Jean
slepian and I live in Stoddard in chure
county and first of all I'd like to
thank all of the people who brought us
here today representative H
Haskins and the wonderful people in the
legislative Services
office and all the people who maintain
the remote sign in which makes it so
much easier for citizens to
participate and Jamie your committee
assistant who's been so
patient and all the Unseen people who
keep the wheels turning thank thank you
to all of
them I know we're on very limited time
so the basis of my testimony has to do
with the many existing
statutes and administrative rules that
contraindicate the use of glue
traps
um if I look out my window and I see a
bunny rabbit eating apples that have
fallen off one of the trees in my yard
and I go out and beat that bunny rabbit
to death with a baseball bat that's a
felony RSA 2061
19B but if an apple grower puts a glue
trap in an orchard or a Farm Stand and
that bunny rabbit climbs onto that trap
and reaps her skin apart and breaks her
bones in her struggle to get away and
finally succumbs through starvation suff
ification or
dehydration after prolonged
suffering that's what the proponents of
glue traps call a tool in the
toolbox if a professional wildlife
control operator uses any lethal trap
including a glue trap to try to exclude
bats from a structure like an attic or a
barn or a storage shed he'll lose his
license and could face fines and other
penalties but a homeowner can buy a few
glue traps at Walmart put them in his
attic and kill a dozen endangered
bats and there's no consequences for
that at
all now if a person who collects
reptiles and amphibians like salamanders
or snakes if that person uses any method
other than hand capture or handheld net
he could face an adjudicative hearing
fines and other
penalties
but if my neighbor puts glue traps in
her garage and 10 baby snakes crawl onto
those traps and die there's no
accountability at
all it's the intent of the legislature
that any person who causes a wild animal
a fish or a wild bird to be tortured or
mutilated either purposely or
negligently shall be guilty of a
criminal
offense it's the
intention of the state through the
administrative rulemaking
process that bats are unconditionally
protected against lethal trapping there
are eight species of bats in New
Hampshire four are considered endangered
and four are considered threatened I'm
going to have to ask you to conclude
your
comments I'm going to have to ask you to
conclude your comments okay can I have
one a few more seconds just a few more
seconds you've used up your three
minutes um in in the state of New
Hampshire in regard to endangered and
threatened species it is
unlawful it is unlawful for any person
to take such a species and all stated
agencies and departments are are
required to assist in the conservation
of endangered and threatened species by
assuring that any any actions that are
funded or authorize them do not
jeopardize the existence of endangered
and threatened
species and are designed to minimize
harm and and to to minimize harm okay
I'm going to have to ask you to complete
finish your finish your thought and um
we need you to be done because your
three minutes is up okay thank you okay
thanks any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you
appreciate
uh my name is BJ W I live in Sullivan
New Hampshire which is a little Hilltown
near keen and I'm here to uh support
this bill the use of glue traps is
unnecessary extremely cruel and should
definitely be outlawed glue traps are
considered one of the most cruel ways to
kill animals they can cause animals to
suffer from starvation dehydration and
Suffocation as we have heard yeah yeah
both Jean and I are ex Librarians and
we're just quite softspoken um animals
like Jean said can lose fur skin or
feathers the CDC advises against using
glut traps because they can spread
diseases like haav Virus to humans there
are a lot of other methods including
non-lethal ones for catching rodents in
and around your house
in spite of having four cats we do have
a lot of mice and we use a catch and
release trap which at least gives the
mice a Fighting Chance at survival these
are little plastic have a heart type
tracks I really can't believe that
anyone would choose to use a glue trap
but apparently lots of people do with
the unintended consequences of catching
non-target animals such as cats and
kittens Birds snakes and aosom and where
I handed out shows uh includes a few
non-target animals that were caught in
traps you they also catch frogs and
snakes any little creature that comes
across them and usually these animals
have to be then euthanized but even if
these glue traps only caught mice it
would still it should still be outlawed
as they can suffer for days ripping off
their skin and fur breaking Limbs and
even gnawing on their own Limbs and mice
are people too they're tiny yeah and
there are other ways to uh to eradicate
them from your house these traps are
just too cruel there is a similar bill
in the US house as well to make this a
national ban on this product and some
other countries have already done this
so please do the right thing support
this bill
thanks thank you I appreciate you uh
coming to speak with us any questions
from the
committee seeing none and representative
Hawkins my name is Ty Hawkins I am from
Hudson New Hampshire and I am in
opposition to this bill uh I represent
the New England Pest Management
Association as well as Fox Pest Control
who has several branches uh throughout
uh the country especially right here in
Manchester as well as one in um
Massachusetts um the reason for the
opposition I can understand the feelings
and and the difficulties that are faced
when we see non-target animals that are
caught in these traps because that's not
the intention the intention is to trap
rodents for the main cause of control
because of the diseases that they carry
rodents carry 35 diseases including
haunt virus and
salmonella these glue traps are very
effectively used in manufacturing food
food facilities as well as grocery
stores and other places that we are
trying to protect food and other uh um
other objects from um from the types of
diseases that can spread on them when we
hear of Sal manella poisoning and things
like that that happen uh because of
recalls of vegetables in large part it's
due because of the the rodents getting
in these vegetables and and spreading
those those diseases um when we look at
when we look at um the the the Banning
of just rodent adhesive boards that's
impossible to do because rodent boards
and insect boards are the exact same
thing so we need to understand the
ramifications of banning an adhesive
board and what that means outside of
just the rodents that they're intended
to catch yes they do at times catch
non-target animals but that is because
they are used in a way that is against
the label restrictions right on the
product itself when when we use the
product outside and not in an enclosed
space or an enclosed trap it does catch
unintended animals and that's not the
case when they are used appropriately
and according to label so it's very
difficult to be able to ban something
like this when the states of Vermont
Massachusetts and Maine where we can
just go across the border and buy them
it does us no good to ban that here
because it's impossible to
enforce um when we're thinking about the
diseases that these rodents can cause
we're also leaking about the the the
difficulty that insects cause to our
lower income housing people these these
same devices are used to trap literally
hundreds and thousands of cockroaches
which is a main reason why lower income
housing children face the difficulty of
asthma this is a this is a a product
that is used quite extensively within
the pest control industry and it's used
correctly um however not being able to
utilize these things we we we do go back
to a time to where we don't have that
the tools necessary there are several
tools that are snap traps are one that
are very effective but by themselves
they're not they need to be used along
with glue boards and other things
exclusion and some of the other things
that have been
mentioned could you please conclude I'll
stop I'll stop right there yeah okay
representative King thank you madam
chair and thank you for your testimony
today um I understand that
um if an animal I'm seeing pictures here
of uh kittens and large birds being
stuck to glue traps and I understand
that if left there they're going to die
um and I understand that that would they
probably got caught there because of um
improper use and placement of the traps
but I'm just curious sounds like you
have extensive U knowledge and use of
these traps if you were to get a kitten
or a bird stuck in this trap and you got
to it sufficiently quickly how difficult
is it to remove the bird or the kitten
from the glue trap uh or is it like
guaranteed they're going to lose skin
and fur and it just be a total nightmare
or is there like like if you just wet
you know run lots of flushing water will
they get I don't know know is there a
way to remove them there is there's a
way to remove them quite easily and
effectively now the the glue itself is
very sticky however something as simple
as vegetable oil used against the skin
or the fur right up against the glue
releases that glue rather easily to help
save that animal and to be able to
prevent it from being being harmful what
needs to happen is there just needs to
be more education on how to properly use
these things and how we can uh utilize
the tools that we have to help prevent
this from happening because it can be
prevented it's just a matter of whether
whether or not we want to go about the
correct
way represent Bixby so are there
um are there glue
boards particularly that would uh excuse
me are there glue boards that are
designed with covers on them or or can
they be put into um covered containers
yes as a way of excluding non-target
animals yes yes and this is widely used
in The Pest Control industry in fact the
prop that we aren't supposed to use is
actually designed to hold a glue board
itself when it catches rodents it can
catch them live if you don't have a glue
board in there however what happens when
the mice are in there alone or when
they're in there together they actually
just chew each other apart and mutilate
and fight and so it's no in it's not in
more in it's not less inhumane to put to
use one of those stations without a glue
board what we're doing with the glue
board is preventing that Mouse from
being able to be trapped all right for
being able to escape and be able to
spread that potential diseases one of
the issues that we see in the pest
control industry often is customers who
do want to relocate the mice and they
put them back outside well within a
matter of hours they're finding their
way back inside because of the fairmon
that they leave behind they have very
sensitive fairmon very sensitive noses
to where they can scent and smell the
phermones Left Behind from either their
fur or their feces or their urine and it
just attracts them right back to where
they're out so you're basically
recycling the mouse coming in and coming
out and you're probably doing more harm
to it than if you were just to get rid
of it in the first place but in reality
what we're talking about is is uh is the
ability to protect human and health and
safety The Pest Control industry again
who uses these these devices widely is
really the third large or the third most
um viable option when it come when it
comes to protecting health and safety
minus medication and medical advances
it's the pest control is a reason why uh
Health has become better and people have
be have started to live longer because
of that life expend dency has expanded
over the last several years because of
the the the safety in which we provide
to food sources and things like that uh
I have a question yes since you're in
the pest control industry how long has
the pest control industry been using
glue boards it has been a while for sure
um I've been in the pest control
industry for 20 years and they've been
used uh within that amount of time uh
and even longer because it is very
effective it's very economical and when
used appropriately very Humane and also
um for use of this
um is this part
of a plan like you have integr I've
heard of integrated Pest Management is
that something that you know you use
some in some instances and some in other
instances or not in other instances yeah
so what integrated Pest Management is
it's it's an entire process on how we
treat uh for insects and other pests
including rodents and what that includes
is anything that goes from exclusion to
monitoring to trapping to the glue
boards to the use of of chemical
products right we use a wide range of
different things to make it so it's most
effective to be able to get rid of of
what the what whatever the issue is and
so if we were to ban these glue boards
we would essentially have to write very
a lot of different laws that are are
actually written for the The Pest
Management right and that would that
would include uh those things that are
that are that are overseen by the New
Hampshire Department of
Agriculture they would need to rewrite
several laws in order to take out the
glue boards because they are included in
that language you in the integrated Pest
Management language yes I see yes uh
representative H Haskins thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question did I understand you correctly
to say that you believe glue boards are
Humane when they're used in the correct
way they can be because glue boards
should be checked on a regular basis
right rather than just leaving them
forgetting about them they should be
checked on a regular basis so that way
if there are unintended catches they can
be released safely follow up follow
and I was also wondering if you do um
exclusion mitigation for the complexes
that you say uh they are effective for
Co cockroaches are you helping those
buildings do exclusionary mitigation yes
yes we are doing exclusion on those
however when you're dealing with
cockroaches you can't exclude them from
the outside because they come from food
sources and come from only the inside in
fact the German cockroach who carries
the most disease is and it's the most
most uh common roach that we face in New
Hampshire those ones are brought in only
by food and from the inside they're not
brought in from the outside they cannot
live outside they have to live inside
and so the proper use of of glue boards
when utilizing those insects is used
inside in protective areas to where they
can won't be handled by those
individuals who are not intended
to yes representative King thank you
again Madam chair if you are using these
glue boards and you check them regularly
I'm assuming you routinely find the
intended targets rodents alive what do
you do with the rodent once you find it
alive we dispose of them as quickly as
we can you kill it yes how how do you do
that uh it depends on it depends on what
we have available too right um we may
just try and and do what we have we we
aren't able to carry firearms and we
can't leth we can't do that type of
thing which which can be um drowning
it's as as as as terrible as it sound is
one of the ways in which we dispose of
them because it can be done quickly it's
in my opinion because of the diseases
that these mice carry and the rodents
carry it's far better to have them
experience that than to have someone be
able to have salmonella or haunted virus
or those things that can can potentially
be lethal to several thank you any other
questions from the committee
representative
Penza um thank you madam chair and sorry
I'm coming in late I just um I was here
last term for this um for this bill so I
just had a question about um the glue
boards that you're talking about so the
commercial ones that I assume that
you're using the so the ones that we use
yes are commercially but they can also
be available to anybody that wants to
buy them on the Internet yes yeah so
that was my question so you're saying
the ones that you're using someone can
buy on the internet correct okay yep
thank you that's all I need
representative wheeler would you like to
take your
seat any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you for your
Monty good afternoon Madam chair and
members of the committee my name is
Ashley Monty and I'm speaking on behalf
of people for the ethical treatment of
animals and are more than 30 1,000
members and supporters in New Hampshire
to express our strong support for HB
152 over the course of this hearing you
have heard many different arguments in
favor of advancing this bill and banning
glue trps glue traps excuse me across
the state I will focus on one of them
the impact that glut traps have on
animals glut traps inflict an unman
manageable amount of suffering on gentle
animals and they are the single most
inhumane Wild life control product
currently
available because they are designed to
catch animals rather than instantly kill
them animals caught in these traps are
left to suffer long and painful deaths
after their paws Tails beaks or snouts
get stuck to the glue trapped animals
panic and try desperately to escape
often tearing off chunks of their fur
feathers or skin recognizing that they
will die if they cannot free themselves
from the traps some animals even break
bones or chew off their own limbs their
eyes nostrils and mouths may become
glued shut before they eventually die
from starvation dehydration or blood
loss most people who purchase glue traps
are completely unprepared to find a live
animal caught in the glue thrashing in
pain and crying in agony even though
they set the traps themselves some
people who find a small struggling
terrified animal will try their best to
help but others have reported drowning
trapped animals bludgeoning them to
death or throwing the trap in the
garbage while the animal stuck to the
Trap is still alive for every person who
is heartbroken and horrified to see what
glue traps do to animals there are
countless others who simply leave these
traps in their attic their basement or
their garage out of sight and out of
mind where the traps catch animals and
subject them to unbearable pain and a
slow and violent death one that we would
never let go on if we would had to
witness it ourselves no animal no matter
their species should be subjected to
this cruelty HP 152 will protect
countless animals across the state and
help steer us toward a more sensible
effective and compassionate Solutions we
completely understand this committee's
desire to avoid regulations that dictate
the way that people live their lives but
this isn't that this bill is focused
solely on taking one unbelievably cruel
product out of the marketplace to
eliminate a substantial amount of avoid
voidable animal suffering we know that's
something that all of us can get behind
thank you for your time and
consideration thank you I'd like to ask
you
um do you think the kind of trap where a
rodent goes up to the top of a bucket
and falls into a bucket and the mouse or
rodent is drowned is also
cruel yes yeah okay um but the focus of
this bill is just on glue trap so I just
like to remind the committee um I'm just
trying to get a sense of uh of perhaps
what kinds of methods to uh eradicate uh
rodents which are carriers of disease
which kinds of methods you believe are
not cruel yeah I mean Peta found
Foundation has tons of resources on
their website providing um people step
by step on how to not only prevent sort
of the situation where you might have a
mouse coming into your home but then
Humane ways that you can if you find
yourself in that situation where you do
have a mouse in your house um to you
know capture and release that mouse in a
humane way without actually killing the
mouse okay but what in what about in
situations where it's not just one Mouse
but you have maybe hundreds of
mice I I appreciate the question um I
would still just emphasize that there
are solutions that are sensible and
compassionate that do not require the
cruel killing of the the mice um and I
don't have examples with me right now to
sort of explain but um would just refer
the committee to the Plenty of resources
that are available um on peta's
website you representative Bixby so
would you consider um having a uh a cat
in the house that would um uh catch mice
uh a uh a Humane approach or would that
also be cruel you know that's an
interesting question and I'm actually
not positive on peta's stance on that so
I can't answer that question okay thank
you okay uh any other questions from the
committee do you have written testimony
Darby thank you representative for your
patience and waiting for us and I'm
sorry this uh is going a little
late I can see you're having a great day
today so um thank you uh um chairwoman
Aaron uh honorable members of the uh
environmental and agriculture uh
committee um I am representative will
Darby from Hillsboro District 11
representing the welcoming people of
national award 8 I'll try to be brief
and not repeat what other people said so
I'm no fan of mice I uh I have an old
house and a much older Camp I go through
more um mouse traps snap traps on a
yearly basis than I I'm uh I care to
admit um but I am worried about um and
the reason I co-sponsored this bill is
because I do worry about um the the
non-target species the unintended catch
of um of these glue traps um and I also
personally um even though I'm honestly
no fan of PETA um don't think that um
that uh Lut traps are ethical um like uh
was mentioned they lead to starvation
and dehydration as they're left for days
weeks or months um I think to answer a
question that was asked earlier I think
that one of the reasons people buy these
as opposed to snap traps is because they
believe that they're easier to use than
snap traps are um but I think that's
deceptive um if you just do a little bit
of research you'll find that um as has
been testified people don't know what to
do with the mice when they catch them
they're like I've got the live mouse how
do I get rid of it they they uh they ask
questions on the internet and people say
smash it which is fine I got no problem
with smashing the mouse but um but most
people that are are trying to catch
these are that's not really their Forte
so they just walk away and and leave
them you know to ultimately to starve
and um and die due to lack of water um
they also get bit sometimes they're like
I got to pick this thing up and throw it
away because the mous mice is squealing
and they get bit which you know you
we're talking about trans transmitting
diseases um and they also can just rot
which you know is even worse in terms of
spreading the disease throughout the
house so people may have heard that uh
from you know people um my my colleagues
in the house may know that I'm an
Outdoorsman I'm a Hunter um I have uh
both friends and relatives that are
Trappers and I have no problem in in in
support trapping um as a as an outdoor
activ it um but Trappers do have actual
rules that they have to follow um they
they design traps to avoid trapping uh
non-target species they um for the most
part they have to CCH uh check their
traps on a regular basis or even in the
case of underwater beaver traps like
every uh every three days it's um they
have to go through training and they
have to be
licensed um ultimately um I don't think
that adhesive uh based Road and Tra are
um are the right solution for killing
mice I think there's better Solutions um
and I think that there's better uh
better options for everyday um homebased
P control thank you very much thank you
appreciate that
um any questions from members of the
committee seeing none thank you um I
have three cards left if there's anybody
else who hasn't submitted a card who
wishes to speak please fill out a card
and let me know know because I'm just
trying to manage some time
representative H Haskins can you please
take your
seat okay seeing none um I call Rob
Johnson to come speak
afternoon thank you madam chair I am
still Rob Johnson policy director at the
New Hampshire Farm Bureau and we are
opposed to House Bill 152 is direct
drafted um rodent control is is
particularly needed on a farm and you
know where grain is is uh stored and fed
and also where as you heard had some
bills recently where there's you know
value added food production often the
you know the buyers of their food they
require a plan and our Farmers often
will you know hire service for that but
there why why are they uh these traps
use well again and again I'm told
they're effective at a relatively low
cost is one the second thing and the
most important thing that they um my
members tell me is it's not a poison I'm
trying to get away from Poison I don't
want to use a poison uh the traps are
effective I don't and so that it's not a
poison and the third thing I hear is I
need options um yeah there are
alternatives out there that many of them
have tried and they're just simply not
as effective in closing
I wanted to mention that it was uh as
far as outdoor use um that's off label
and I have uh and not heard of any any
these Farmers my members I work with
that are using them Outdoors they're
they're used in uh in an enclosed area
whether it be indoors or in a in a in a
you know a box or something like that
thank you I'll leave it at that okay
thank you I have a question oh I'll let
representative King and then Bixby thank
you madam chair I hope this question
isn't unfair to ask but before the
Advent of glue traps and snap traps what
did farmers use to protect their grain
my guess is cats
usually you store your barn your Gren in
the barn it's cats okay thank you very
much I that's what I use repres
representative
uh
so so
um yes uh so when you uh when you
introduced yourself and your testimony
you said that you're opposed to it as
drafted is does that suggest that you
see a potential uh amendment to
this other than I
said on label use is using them
appropriately I don't know if you would
need legislation for that but as you
know in in whether it be indoors or in
enclosed areas I mean that's okay so so
you would you would you wouldn't mind
some legislation that uh
simply um emphasize the requirement for
on label on label
use and uh there might be an enforcement
cost to
that okay that was my next question so
um all right uh I had one other qu well
I'll someone if someone else has a
question sure I have a question uh do
most Farmers or farmers in the Farm
Bureau utilize integrated Pest
Management oh most definitely most
definitely do they use any of these um
glue Boards out in Orchards where they
can't spray things or no not not outside
no what kind of pest control do they use
out in the orchard areas do you know
that's a good good question what I don't
know what would be what would be needed
out away from a a structure I mean the
the the pest control they're using are
more like would be for insects you know
the I think last the bill you heard last
year wasn't as as defined as this to
rodents and I know we did have issues
there because they do use use uh um oh
like an orchard they pheromone traps and
they're they're they will hang like a a
that looks like the fruit and that has
the sticky substance on it and will'll
capture you know insects that way do you
have any sense of of
um the cost of pest damage like rodent
damage to crops in New Hampshire is
there you know it probably is I don't
have that at the top of my head no
thinking about Orchards again I mean
you've all been out to an orchard and
seen on especially a younger star
there's a you know a like a little fence
or or or a uh around the base of a a uh
um a tree or or some they'll be they'll
be painted that type of thing and do you
feel that uh just as a spokesperson for
New Hampshire Farm Bureau that banning
glue boards as stated in this bill would
be detrimental to the agricultural
Community we do we do again what
my my members will loud and clay with me
on this bill is it it it gets me away
from pesticides that's what I don't want
to use if I don't have to okay thank you
representative Bixby yeah so I
remembered my other question um and this
actually has to do with the grain
storage issue and also uh food
preparation area issue and food storage
which is
um uh one of the standard ideas behind
uh that that's or alternatives to um
various sorts of deadly Pest Control is
mouse what from from a particular
structure Barn from a from a storage
area what what what sort of what's how
how how fine a um um protection or how
what size of a an aperture can a mouse
go through I I there people behind me I
know that can answer that question much
better but I know i' I've seen you know
I've seen footage where there'll be a
you know a concrete uh foundation and
they're walking right you know
diagonally right up the foundation I I
think it's very very small area but
again there are people behind me that
probably could tell you in much more
detail and better than what I'm telling
you thank
you okay any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank
you again are there any other pink cards
again am John O'Brien
Amherst um so uh Tyler but I forgot his
last name behind me our rep from The
Pest Control industry mentioned all the
diseases that rodents carry wanted to
point out that the CDC does not
recommend the glue traps to protect
human health because uh bites as rep
Darby rep uh mentioned and the trapped
animals often defecate or urinate which
can spread diseases um in another way so
they have their own you know downside um
I have to address drowning uh drowning
is not
euthanasia um euthanasia is defined as a
good death which is quick and painless
and drowning is not and this came up
yesterday in the hearing for Senate Bill
290 which is Senator wat's Bill to add a
definition of torture to statute and um
I just have to say please don't don't
dump a stuck Mouse into a into a bucket
of water and don't fill a bucket of
water and put your sunflower seeds on
top and let the mice drown because
that's not a quick painless death um we
have a federal law the federal PCT act
preventing an cruelty and torture that
specifically lists drowning suffocating
burning impaling as forms of
torture and if you brought your pet to
the vet because your pet was old or
suffering and your vet said well let's
how about drowning I think you you'd be
horrified so I just have to get that out
there and lastly uh even even in
research there is um a resistance to
drowning and UNH was cited recently by
um the
USDA inspecting veterinarian because
they drowned 670 animals in a research
study and in her report the um
inspecting veterinarian explains that
euth that drowning is not a form of
euthanasia and that they should have
looked for another method thank you okay
I have a question um so in your opinion
what are the suggested methods in order
to control a mouse infestation when
we're talking about 00 mice in a in a
storage facility thank you and I think
rep Haskin started out with a list for
us um exclusion is the gold standard if
you've got cockroaches you've got food
so get rid of all these things close up
all the holes if if you end up with a
trapped Mouse somehow I would say blunt
force trauma you know if that's the way
to end their life quickly Don't Drown
um thank you madam chair and thank you
for my question um you might not be able
to answer this so um and I'm just it's
been a long time since I used um and I
didn't even use it so we had a pest
control company uh was when we lived in
conquer there was some mice when we
moved into the house and um there were
glue glue traps that were in the
basement none of them worked uh they
just got a lot of um dirt on them and
and dead bugs but um what we ended up
using were the no kill traps that had
like a little peanut butter in there and
um and and we were able to use that so I
just I don't really know um and then
immediately we went through and this is
what everybody should be doing I guess
is we sealed our whole house and stuff
like that but I don't I guess I don't
really understand what pesticide
companies are doing it and they're doing
it efficiently and I and you know
they're not leaving things for days or
weeks or months on end so I don't um I
don't think that that's happening so
what is is there any I mean do we gas
out an infestation do we do anything
that I don't like poison at all because
um I just feel as if that that scares me
especially with other animals that eat
um my so what what's what else is out
there besides a snap trap and glue traps
what else is there really is there any
other yeah thank you and thank you for
caring enough to ask that question um so
it's all back to the whole IPM model you
know you you start with the the big
basic things sealing up the house um you
can remove them live you can just all
the things that you've mentioned of
course you don't want to use the poisons
because that then will affect the
wildlife you know the secondary effects
of
that you know that's you just go down
the list to to to do the least damaging
thing
first any other questions from the
committee see none thank you very much
all right down to my last pin card
Brady this is a big
chair good afternoon thank you I'm
Daniel Brady from Hollis New Hampshire
and I also have uh pest control company
in Manchester and I'm on the New England
Pest Management Association board as
well as the national Pest Management
Association public policy committee um
on their board as
well the uh and we oppose at all of
those levels this bill um we we
recognize the importance of doing our
job safely and humanely we
recognize um our goal is to protect
health and home and part of that
includes food food production uh food uh
establishments breweries hotels
restaurants and any any commercial
building really and as well as your
residential homes and glue boards are an
important part of the IPM program which
we've mentioned which is integrated Pest
Management and it starts off with
identifying the pest you can't identify
the pest if you don't see it glue boards
provide the opportunity to capture that
Pest and then follow other labels
because in New Hampshire label requires
Target Pest and Target site without a
glue board to be able to properly
Identify some of these problems we can't
just go off somebody saying I heard a
mouse we have to go off facts and what
we find and what we have as evidence and
so if we've removed the ability for
these glue boards to capture and hold
them it would not be possible to do IPM
so we would just have to skip those
steps and go straight to chemical that's
the only
all commercial buildings if you if you
deal with food in the state of New
Hampshire you're required ired to have
an IPM program by law so that would now
be out the window because now every
food manufacturer distributor storage
anything would have to just have rodent
control that would be no way of to
Monitor and no way to um assess the
severity of the infestation or what's
going on to even apply for like schools
you can use them and then you can apply
for uh special permits to use
rodenticide well we wouldn't have that
ability without the tool um there are
many many tools and I've tried all of
them the the birth control by sensee the
good nature a24 or
a24a um pneumatic things traps uh M have
a heart things there's myriads of ways
to control rodents and they all don't
work the same way rodents have um unique
and peculiar habits and ability to
control them requires multiple tools I
know it's not fun just to say it's
another tool in the toolbx but if if
what we have doesn't work then we have
no way to do it as far as using a glue
board
outside if it's a paper glue board New
Hampshire's pretty damp they will they
won't last the the the paper
disintegrates quickly um it needs to be
inside an enclosed container so it's not
just going to be left out there for
months and months for non-target um
animals or whatever to get into it they
will become ineffective and those that
that are plastic based if they're not
within a enclosed container what happens
is the film develops on top of that glue
with dust and dirt and other debris and
they become again ineffective due due to
just the environment unless they're in a
enclosed container that mitigates non
non-target um captures again more often
than not the problem is not the pest
industry it's people improperly using
these products um and again this is just
our last last not last but our main
non-chemical ability and non-
rodenticide ability to control rodents
okay representative Bixby so what do you
do for Mouse
exclusion that's the first thing you do
you got to figure out where they're
coming from because otherwise you're
just harvesting mice and we're not in
the industry of or the business of
growing and farming mice so you've got
to exclude them the problem is and it's
not just mice it's rats as well and you
can't really permanently exclude
anything because they gnaw they can GW
through concrete they can GW through um
steel they can GW through I mean as
we've heard another testimony they've
chewed through doors and other sweeps
and things that you use to exclude them
so exclusion is an important component
that you start with um because that's
honestly it's a lot of the times the
easiest way to do it is to create it but
they can get through the whole a mouse
can get through you know less than a/
quarter inch so the size of a dime
you're going to have to go seal every
single dime sized hole along the
foundation of a home or along any type
of building and then you've also got to
prevent them from chewing through it
which we don't have the ability to do
that with our current construction
material that there's always something
wires they can chew through a conduit
entrance um other material that is Gable
if that's a word um it is important and
we do that you you need to exclude but
if that's the only thing you do you're
just closing the door and they have the
ability to open that door
again okay um yeah I have a question
first I wanted to have you speak a
little bit about especially since you
have background in this uh in this uh
field um speak a little bit about the um
Mouse
contraceptives how
long but by the time that those foods
that are la with mouse contraceptives
how long between the time you put those
out and the time you see any kind of
results in reduction or elimination of
the mouse
population um so there's a lot of
factors that come into that depending on
what species it is you know whether it's
a house mouse a field mouse white a deer
mouse a rat I mean each species has
different gestation and different
breeding periods and so it's that's not
a lethal
um method and so you won't see any
results or any reduction in rodent
population until something kills them
and you know so under certain
circumstances it could be years with
mice and rats living if nothing kills
them they just would have to have a
continual supply of the contraceptive
because it's not a permanent
sterilization so you would be feeding
them this contraceptive forever and if
if they miss a feeding of it they're now
able to breed and reproduce and so
you're you're getting stuck behind it um
so you would see a reduction though
because of you know natural they die
they fall in a wall they get trapped
natural predation so you you would see
um a reduction but without something
killing them you we'll we'll crush it
that way and it's it's goal thank you
any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you and we
are out of pink cards for today um so I
am going to ask for the uh blue sheet up
there I do have on the online portal
here um we
have 281 people signed in support of
this bill 10 in
opposition and on the blue sheet
here 2 281 and 10 in opposition
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 people in
support on the blue sheet zero opposed
and I'm going to close out this hearing
for HB 152 and thank you everyone for
and do I hear a adjournment like to make
a motion to adjourn I hear a second
second okay all those in favor I thank
you all right our committee will be back
4th have a v have a good vacation this
committee actually respects vacation yes
vacation
e